PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES LIMIT NONESSENTIAL-
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE. THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. HOWEVER
ALL SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
BE PARTICIPATING NOW WILL NOT
MISS WILLIS IS NOT HERE HE WILL
BE HERE. REMOTELY OKAY M. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PERMITTED PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
FEEDBACK I S. IT EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO RECOGNIZE THAT USED TO
RAISE HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR. ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO UN MUTE PLEASE
SELECT A MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING OUR IT PERSONNEL PUT
YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE
DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE OR IS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE TODAY. IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE.
SEVEN SIX ZERO EIGHT. DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK
PLEASE MEET YOUR DEVICE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED.
OUT WITH EVERY F. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IS CLOSE IN
THE SAME MANNER AS CUSTOMER
CARE MAYBE LACKS WE ASKED
EVERYBODY BE PATIENT. I'M IN
TODAY'S HEARING WILL REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
RELATING TO CAL WORKS CALFRESH
FOOD ASSISTANCE AND HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. I WILL NOT THE L.
GENDE ITEMS WILL BE UP FOR
DISCUSSION BUT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL NOT BE VOTING ON ANY ITEMS
TODAY. WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THE HEARING AFTER
ALL ITEMS HAVE BEEN HEARD. OUR
FIRST PRESENTATION. IS ON THE
FIRST AGENDA ITEM FROM. CAL
WORKS. REGARDING KOBE NINETEEN
RELIEF. IN THE AGAIN THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE. SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. OKAY. SO FOR EACH
AGENDA ITEM I THINK WE'RE READY
TO GO AHEAD WITH. ONE OF.
COERCE COVERED RELIEF. GOOD
AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS
AFTERNOON AND KIM JOHNSON.
WELCOME THANK YOU. I CAN
JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES I'M GOING TO PROVIDE
YOU SOME VERY BRIEF OPENING
REMARKS AND THEN TURN IT OVER
TO THE TEAM TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE OUTLINED IN
THE AGENDA A COUPLE PANDEMIC
HAS HAD A PROFOUND IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO WERE ALREADY EXPERIENCING
POVERTY. THE SYSTEMIC
INEQUITIES THAT CREATE
DISPARITIES FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
WERE HIDING FROM THE EARLY DAYS
OF THE PANDEMIC LATE LAST
WINTER TO THE EFFORTS THAT TOOK
SHAPE IN THE SPRING SUMMER AND
FALL ALL AREAS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAVE BEEN WORKING TO CARRY OUT
OUR MISSION TO SERVE EIGHT IN
PROTECT COMMUNITIES. THE TEAMS
WORKED AT AN UNPARALLELED PACE
CREATING NEW PROGRAMS AND
APPROACHES IN A MATTER OF DAYS
OR WEEKS WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN TERMS
OF THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
SPACE THAT YOU'LL HEAR ON YOUR
AGENDA AT THIS YEAR'S- LOOK IN
THE PANDEMIC HAS LOOKED LIKE
THINGS LIKE READING PROJECT
ROOM HE PART OF A ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. IN EMERGENCY
HOMELESS AID THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE MADE
AVAILABLE TO COMBAT THE
NINETEEN PROJECT GROUP ROOM
KEEP THE DATA SUPPORTED OVER
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND OF OUR
AND SHELTERED NAPE NEIGHBORS
PROVIDING. SHELTER AND
WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS. OF COURSE
ADDRESSING. WAS A PRIMARY FOR
THE GUY IN THIS. PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
INDIVIDUALS OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
POPULATION THAT ARE AND
SHELTERED ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL BUILDS ON THE SUCCESS
OF PROJECT BRING HE AND HOME HE
PROPOSING A PACKAGE OF
INVESTMENTS TOTALING ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
FURTHER DEVELOP A BROADER
PORTFOLIO OF HOUSING. UNITS TO
END HOMELESSNESS THROUGH
CONTINUED ACQUISITION AND
CREATION OF UNITS. YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES OUR PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISHTHE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM PROVIDING TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION. ONE
TIME DOLLARS OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. THESE TWO ACQUIRE OR
REHAB ADULT CARE. THIS
INITIATIVE ALSO SUPPORTS THE
EXPANSION OF RESOURCES ACROSS
THE LONG TERM CARE CONTINUUM
BRIDLES. AND WE WILL COURSE
CONTINUE TO LEVERAGE OUR
HOUSING SUPPORTS LIKE THE
CALORIES HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND HOLDS AN EXTENSIVE
PRE. ELECTION AND MAINTAIN
STABILITY FOR HOUSEHOLDS. IN
CALFRESH TO ADDRESS HUNGER
ACROSS THE STATE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO QUICKLY OPERATIONALIZE.
AND ISSUE NEW YORK RESOURCES
LIKE PANDEMIC EBT WHICH
SUPPORTED MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WHO LOST
ACCESS TO FREE AND REDUCED
PRICE SCHOOL MEALS. ON CAMPUSES
WERE CLOSED AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC IN MARCH. IN OUR
BROADER CALPERS PROGRAM INTO
THE WORK WE DID WITH THE
LEGISLATURE A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO EXPAND
CALFRESH BENEFITS TO SSI
RECIPIENTS. AND HAVE MORE OLDER
ADULTS GETTING CALFRESH THAN
EVER BEFORE. TOTALING OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
AND TWENTY TWENTY. FRESHEN
ROMAN AMONG ADULTS AGE SIXTY
AND OVER HAS GONE UP BY ONE
HUNDRED AND 35% IN JUST THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS. THIS
MEANT THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC
THESE HOUSEHOLDS WERE ALSO ABLE
TO BENEFIT FROM THE ADDITIONAL
EMERGENCY ALLOTMENT
SUPPLEMENTS. IN TOTAL
REPRESENTING OVER ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL. BENEFITS FOR
HOUSEHOLDS. I'LL WHEN I REALLY
APPRECIATE ARE PART WITH THIRD
TO BE TRICKED TREMENDOUS WORK
ACROSS. AND THIS GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES ADDITIONAL
EXPANSION TO MEET THE NEEDS WE
ESTIMATE THAT BY MID TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE SPEED BANKS. WILL HAVE
DISTRIBUTED ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN FOOD AND
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS DOLLARS
IN DIAPER ASSISTANCE. AND
PROVIDE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN RESPECT THAT REIMBURSEMENT
FOR. EXPENSES THE TRAINING TO
CAL WORKS YOUR FIRST ITEM ON
THE AGENDA THIS AFTERNOON WE'VE
INSTITUTED A NUMBER OF
FLEXIBILITIES IN THIS PROGRAM
TO ENSURE FAMILIES CONTINUED
ACCESS TO BENEFITS AND DIDN'T
EXPERIENCE TRYING TO PROGRAM.
THIS LOOKS LIKE FACE TO FACE
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS BEING
WAVES TO ALLOW FAMILIES TO
RECEIVE THEIR FULL SIXTEEN DAY
ALLOTMENT OF HOW WORKS
TEMPORARY HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
AND FRIENDS. AT PROVIDING HOW
WORKS AT DIVERSION AND
EXPANSION OF THAT PROGRAM SO
FAMILIES GET BBC ASSISTANCE
DURING THE CRISIS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS A
ONE POINT 5% INCREASE TO CAO
WORKS MAXIMUM AID PAYMENT
LEVELS EFFECTIVE OCTOBER. LATER
THIS YEAR. IN CONCLUSION
GOVERNOR'S BAD PROPOSALS LOOK
TO MAKE BOLD INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL HELP POSITION THE STATE TO
BEGIN AN EQUITABLE AND BROAD
BASED RECOVERY ADDRESSING THE
IMMEDIATE RESOURCES FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN NEED AS WELL AS
BOLSTERING THE CRITICAL SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ACROSS THE STATE. AND ON.
SUPPORTING SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY AND IMPROVING THE
HEALTH AND WELLBEING ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES SO GETTING ONE-
FREE **** ALL OF OUR PARTNERS
FOR THE TREMENDOUS WORK. I WILL
THEN TURN TO YOUR QUESTIONS AND
YOUR GENDER AND I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE FAMILY ENGAGEMENT. ECONOMY
ENGAGEMENT. DIVISION JENNIFER.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER HERNANDEZ WITH A
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT AND
EMPOWERMENT DIVISION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL. SERVICES
I WILL TAKE ON THE FIRST
QUESTION AROUND OUR BUDGET
PROPOSALS RELATED. TO CAL
WORKS- RESPONSE TO KOBE
NINETEEN RELIEF- SO THE FIRST
ITEM I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT IS
OUR CONTINUATION OF THE
CULVERTS TIME ONE EIGHT
EXEMPTION. AS YOU KNOW AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES AN EXTENSION TO THE
CAL WORKS TIME ON EIGHT
EXEMPTION. WHICH ARE
ESSENTIALLY PAS THE FORTY EIGHT
MONTH TIME LIMIT- BY EXEMPTING
ANY MONTH OR PARTIAL MONTH OF
CAL WORKS EIGHT. FROM COUNTY
TOWARDS AN INDIVIDUAL'S FORTY
EIGHT MONTH TIME LIMIT. AND SO
THROUGH THIS FLEXIBILITY
PARTICIPANTS CAN CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THEIR AID WITHOUT ANY
DISRUPTION OF ANY OF THE
CRITICAL SERVICES THAT ARE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. THROUGHOUT
THE COMPANY NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND SO- CURRENTLY THIS.
EXTENSION IS SET TO EXPIRE ON
APRIL THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WHEN WE WILL BE
TRANSITIONING TO THE CAL WORK
SIXTY MONTH TIME LIMIT- AS YOU
RECALL ABOUT. POLICY CHANGE ON
PLACE YEAR. AND THE COST OF
THIS PARTICULAR EXTENSION IS
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION FOR-
TWENTY TWENTY THROUGH TWENTY
ONE. AND THEN IS ESTIMATED AT
FORTY SIX POINT ONE MILLION
FOUR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. THE
SECOND ITEM I'D LIKE TO CALL
OUT HERE IS OUR EFFORTS AROUND
SUPPORTING THE SUCCESS- FORWARD
FOR A REMOTE ACCESS FOR CLIENTS
AND SO IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
YOU'LL SEE PROPOSED ITEMS- THAT
SUPPORT REMOTE LEARNING
OPTIONS. INCLUDING REMOTE
ACCESS- FOR- CAL WORKS AND CAL
FIRST EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
PARTICIPANTS- SO THESE
RESOURCES ARE REALLY CRITICAL
TO HELP EXPAND REMOTE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES- ONE- PARTNERSHIP
THAT I'D REALLY LIKE TO CALL
OUT IS OUR WORK WITH CELL AND-
WHICH IS- A CELLPHONE BASED
APPLICATION THAT HELPS TO
PROVIDE VOCATIONAL TRAINING-
DIGITAL LITERACY AND DIGITAL
NAVIGATION INCLUDING- SOME
CITIZENSHIP COURSE WORK AND
OTHER CIVIC. COURSES THAT
REALLY HELP TO PROVIDE TRAINING
AND PROVIDE CERTIFICATE
OPTIONS- FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ON A CAREER PATHWAY
AND SO THAT'S BEEN A REALLY
CRITICAL- WAY FOR CHINESE TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS- REMOTE SERVICES
AND IT'S CURRENTLY OPERATIONAL
IN OVER FORTY COUNTIES- IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE FUNDS WILL
ALSO BE USED TO SUPPORT THE
PURCHASE OF- SMARTPHONES WILL
ALSO BE- DISTRIBUTING HOT SPOTS
AND- AND PROVIDING ACCESS TO
BRENT BROADBAND SERVICES
INCLUDING LAPTOPS AND TABLETS.
TO ENSURE THAT OUR PARTICIPANTS
ARE AGAIN ABLE TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION AND TRAINING-
RESOURCES- PROGRAMS RIGHT AND
SO THESE SERVICES WOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND- PARTICIPANTS OVER A
SIX MONTH PERIOD. BEGINNING AND
THIS YEAR AND THE COST OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET YEAR. I'M IF WE NEED TO
IF THEY ARE ANY. AROUND THIS WE
CAN GO ON TO THE SECOND ITEM.
BUT THE INCREASES REMAIN OR THE-
NINETEEN I RELIEF IF THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS WE CAN GO ON TO
THE CASE WITH QUESTION NUMBER
TWO. GIVE. YEAH THE QUICK
QUESTION OKAY SO I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE BRETT
HAUSER TO KICK US OFF ON THE
CASELOAD- OVERALL IT WAS SORT
OF A DATE AND THEN I'LL DIG
INTO A FEW DETAILS. HE'S ME I'M
A CHRISTIAN HELP US UNDER
MELINDA'S. IF YOU I DON'T FOR
SOME REASON I DON'T HAVE HER
RAISING AN OPTION HERE SO I'M
JUST GONNA HAVE TO INTERJECT.
I'M YES I JUST HAVE A QUICK ONE
HOW MANY- MANY PEOPLE ARE
PARTICIPATING IN. THE CHARACTER
GREAT. CURRENT. THAT'S THE
UPDATE THAT IRAN IS GOING TO
GIVE IN TERMS OF OUR CASELOAD.
OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRENT HOUSE OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN
EVERYONE HEAR ME OKAY. YES
WONDERFUL SO I'LL BE ADDRESSING
AND BRIEF- TESTIMONY THE POWER
X. CASE FOR QUESTION THE RECENT
TRENDS SO BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
DUE TO THE INITIAL IMPACT OF
COPING NINETEEN ON CASELOAD THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
ASSUMED HOW WORKS CASE THAT
WOULD INCREASE IN THE ABSENCE
OF REAL TIME DATA EARLY ON IN
THE PANDEMIC WHICH WAS FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND
CASES. SINCE THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT ACTUAL CASELOAD DATA
FOR JULY TWENTY TWENTY TO
NOVEMBER TWENTY. FIFTH OF JULY
TWENTY. JULY TWENTY TWENTY
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ARE
REFLECTING A DOWNWARD TREND.
FOR THOSE FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF
JULY TO NOVEMBER OF THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR THE AVERAGE NUMBER
OF CAL WORKS CASES THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
WHICH IS ABOUT A 7% DECREASE
FROM. THE AVERAGE MONTHLY
CASELOAD FROM TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY WHICH WAS THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND. I'LL
GIVE IN CASE OF GROWTH HAS NOT
MATERIALIZED TO DATE THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAS REDUCED ITS- CURRENT
YEAR CASELOAD PROJECTION FROM
THE- TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
WHICH WAS FROM FOUR HUNDRED.
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND TO ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIVE THOUSAND CASES AND
PROJECTS A CASELOAD GROWTH- IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND- EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND CASES. I WITH THAT I
WILL SEND IT BACK OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE JENNIFER HERNANDEZ TO
SPEAK TO THE APPLICATION
DENIALS IN EXIT RATE. THANK YOU
BRIAN. I'M TO GIVE YOU TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT IN
TERMS OF THE APPLICATION
DENIALS THE AVERAGE DENIAL RATE
THAT WE SEE FOR APPLICATIONS
DURING THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR IS
SIXTY PERCENT. AND THAT'S
COMPLETE IN COMPARISON TO ABOUT
40% IN THE YEAR PRIOR IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- SO THAT THE TO SORT
OF DRIVERS THAT WERE SEEN- AS
MAIN FACTORS FOR APPLICATIONS
AND I ALSO- HAVE BEEN STABLE
ACROSS BECAUSE IT INCLUDED
PERIODS. AND SO THOSE TWO ARE-
THE FIRST- FAILURE TO COMPLY
WITH PROCEDURAL REQUIREMENTS-
WHICH ESSENTIALLY ARE.
CONSISTENT FOR ABOUT YOU KNOW
50% OF ALL TO NILES IN ANY
GIVEN MONTH- REGARDLESS OF THE
PANDEMIC RATE- THE OTHERS SORT
OF DRIVER IS INCOME THAT
EXCEEDS OUR STANDARDS. AND THE
DOCKS AND ACCOUNTING FOR ABOUT
22% OF THE TOTAL TO NILES- NOW
INITIALLY DURING- THE ONSET OF
COLLUDED- DENIALS IN THIS
CATEGORY WERE LARGELY REDUCED
TO ABOUT 17% OR SO- BUT THEY
SLOWLY STARTED TO INCREASE TO
ABOUT 25% OF THE DONT. DENIALS
IN THE MOST RECENT. SEPTEMBER
OCTOBER AND NOVEMBER OF LAST
YEAR. IN TERMS OF OUR
DISCONTINUANCE- OR WHAT WE CALL
THE EXITS- FROM CAL WORKS PRIOR
TO KOBE THERE WERE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY THOUSAND CASES
EXITING CAL WORKS AND ANY
PARTICULAR MONTH AND SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF COLLUDED WITH THE
RECESSION- WE HAVE STARTED TO
SEE OUR DECREASES- IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY WE HAD ABOUT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND EXITS. IN
APRIL IT WENT DOWN SLIGHTLY TO
ABOUT FIVE- FIVE THOUSAND EXITS
AND THEN IN ME- IT WENT- UP TO
ABOUT NINE THOUSAND EXITS AND
SO BEGINNING IN JUNE OR SO- WE
SAW THAT- CASES WERE COMING
BACK TO NORMAL LEVELS HOWEVER
IN MOST RECENT- THE MOST RECENT
THREE MONTHS OF DATA THAT WE
HAVE WE STARTED TO SEE HIGHER
THAN PRE COBIT LEVELS- OF EXITS
AND THAT'S NEARLY THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND EXITS A MONTH. AND SO
THEN THE TWO FACTORS THAT ARE
DRIVING THIS- BASED ON THE DATA
THAT WE HAVE- IS THE FIRST THAT
YOU KNOW FOLKS THAT ARE
EXCLUDED BY LAW FOR REASONS
OTHER THAN TIME LIMITS AND
CITIZENSHIP SO THIS MAY INCLUDE
CLIENTS WHO ARE DISCONTINUED AT
AS A RESULT OF PERHAPS NOT
COMPLETING THEIR
REDETERMINATION REQUIREMENTS
RIGHT- THAT TENDS TO BE THE
MOST COMMON REASON FOR
DISCONTINUING- INCREASE OVER
TWO MONTHS- COUNTY FOR ABOUT
40% OR SO OF THOSE EXITS-
HOWEVER WE DID SEE THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM DECREASE.
DRAMATICALLY TO ABOUT 8% IN MAY
OF LAST YEAR- BEFORE IT NEARLY-
FOR GOING UP AGAIN I TO ABOUT
70% IN LATE NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY- THE OTHER FACTOR THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED IS DRIVING THE
EXITS IS- EXCESSIVE INCOME AND
SO- THIS TYPICALLY IS A FACTOR
FOR DISCONTINUANCE- AND YOU
KNOW IT SORT OF HAS. HAS
BETWEEN OF LAST YEAR THROUGH NO.
OF LAST YEAR RANGING ANYWHERE
FROM ABOUT. 25% 26% IN TERMS
OF- IT'S CAUSING DISCONTINUANCE
THIS CONTINUANCES OR EXITS- IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE FACTORS
THAT COULD CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
OR PERHAPS YOU KNOW FOLKS ARE
RECEIVING OTHER BENEFITS OR
OTHER PENSION- INCREASES- IN
THAT PARTICULAR LINE ITEM WE
SAW THAT- INCREASE FROM ABOUT
TWENTY. PERCENT 237% SO
DEFINITELY PLAYED A ROLE THERE
AND CONTRIBUTING TO EXITS ON
THE OTHER IS EARNINGS AND SO-
WHAT WE SAW IS THAT IT WENT
FROM ABOUT 80% 265% DURING THE-
EARLY CODE MONTHS- AND BY JUNE
OR SO LAST YEAR OUR RATIOS HAD
RETURNED. TO PRE COOKED AMOUNTS
AND HAVE STAYED. STEADY FOR THE
MOST PART SINCE THAT. ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT. BUT I
GUESS I WOULD I WOULD ASK ARE
WE SEEING SIMILAR THINGS IN
OTHER STATES RIGHT IT SEEMS
LIKE YOU KNOW WE'RE IN THIS
HUGE PANDEMIC IT'S AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
YET OUR CASELOADS ARE DOWN SO
WHERE. WHERE ARE THE PEOPLE
GOING. THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL A LOT OF THE
TICKET HAS BEEN DELAYED- CFN
ASKED- FOR. SORT OF UPDATES
FROM OTHER STATES- WE'VE
CONTINUOUSLY TRIED O. REMAIN
IN CONTACT WITH OTHER STATE
ADMINISTRATORS OF THE KIND OF
PROGRAM- BUT WE DON'T HAVE
SOLID DATA THAT WE CAN POINT
POINT TWO. ON THE OTHER
RESOURCE THAT WE CAN GO TO IS-
THAT MUCH A PROBLEM POLICY
PROJECTS SO. WE CAN FOLLOW UP
AND PROVIDE YOU WITH. ANY
INFORMATION WE RECEIVE BUT WE
JUST DON'T HAVE IT AT THIS TIME
IT JUST IT JUST SEEMS COUNTER
INTUITIVE AND IS YOUR YOUR PLAN
TO DO MORE TELEPHONIC AND-
PHONES AND- DEVICES IS THAT. AN
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
IN TERMS OF ACCESSING REMOTE
SERVICES YES WHAT WE SAW IS
THAT BEING ABLE TO PIVOT AND
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY WILL CERTAINLY ALLOW
THEM TO- ONE CONTINUE TO BE
ENGAGED BUT ALSO- ENSURE THAT
WERE ABLE TO- GIVE THEM THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY NEED TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THEIR
REDETERMINATION RIGHT AND HAVE
ALL OF THOSE OTHER- ISSUES. AT
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AVAILABLE
TO THEM BUT- DEFINITELY OKAY
BUT BUT PEOPLE WON'T HAVE THOSE
DEVICES INTO THEIR ALREADY IN
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY. SO WHAT
ARE WE DOING TODAY. BUT DO WE
HAVE ANYTHING IN PLACE SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY REACHING OUT TO PEOPLE
WHO MAY NEED SERVICES OR THE
COUNTIES WORKING ON. THEY THEY
ARE AND I WILL SAY THAT JUST
HISTORICALLY IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE CERTAINLY TRIED TO BE MORE
PROACTIVE RIGHT. AND SO- PART
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THIS
CELL ED PLATFORM IS REALLY
PROMOTING- IN ASSURING THAT
FOLKS ARE ABLE TO COME BACK
INTO THE COUNTY SYSTEM. AND
ACCESS ADDITIONAL SERVICES-
THERE CERTAINLY HAS BEEN OTHER
PROACTIVE EFFORTS TO CONNECT
AND SHARE INFORMATION. ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENROLL IN- CAL
WORKS IN CALFRESH. THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE HAD
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF OUTREACH
AROUND- SORT OF EITC IN IN IN
ONGOING- SORT OF REACH WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
PROGRAMS AND UNDERSTAND THAT
WERE THERE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
DURING THE PANDEMIC. I THOUGHT
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERYTHING BUT
THIS IS OFTENTIMES THE SAME
DEMOGRAPHIC WERE BEING LEFT OUT
OF THE VACCINE ISSUE WHO HAVE
HIGHER RATES THAN ANYBODY ELSE
SO. IT'S VERY SENSITIVE TO IT
IF THERE'S PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT WE'RE NOT REACHING. AND
COULD BE. BUT ANYTHING. NOTHING
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND I
TOO AM VERY INTERESTED AND-
YOUR CONVERSATION WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUES AND OTHER STATES TO
SEE IS IF OUR EXPERIENCE IS
UNIQUE OR IS IT SIMILAR TO
OTHER STATES- I GUESS WHAT I
QUESTIONS SPARKED A FEW
QUESTIONS- WHEN NOW- YOU KNOW
WE'VE WE GET COVERED WE DID
COME UP- AND- GET. SERVICE
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE LONGEST
ECONOMIC EVEN THOUGH SLOW
EXPANSION ACT EXACTLY
EXPANSIONS IN US ONE THE
QUESTIONS I HAD FOR YOU IS THAT
WE DO PROVIDE A TIME LIMIT FOR
PEOPLE TO BE ON CAO WORKS RIGHT
AND THEN WE EXPECT THEM TO GET
OFF AND IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME
WE TRY TO GET THEM EDUCATION
ANOTHER TYPE THINGS GET A JOB
AND- POTENTIALLY THEY- WERE
ABLE TO. HOPEFULLY SOME MANY OF
THEM WERE ABLE TO GET ONE
DURING THE EXPANSION. THEN
COBIT HEADS. SOME DOUBT THEY
MAY HAVE. BE RECEIVING
UNEMPLOYMENT ARE SO FORTH BUT I
GUESS ARE YOU ABLE TO IDENTIFY-
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT HOW MANY
PEOPLE AND FORTY PRIME MANY OF
THEM WOMEN SOME WOMEN WHICH WE
KNOW HAVE HAD AT A MUCH IGHER
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES ARE
RELEASED- CHALLENGES WITH WITH
COATED WITH EMPLOYMENT-
BASICALLY WOULD'VE LOST THE JOB
AFTER THEY'VE RUN OUT THEIR
TIME AND THEN- AND THEN I
ASSUME THEY CAN'T COME BACK ON
RIGHT. DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
I'M SAYING. I BELIEVE SO YEAH
AS OUR POLL OF THEIR PULL THE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO BASICALLY
YOU KNOW WERE ON. OUR EXPO FOR
RAN UP THEIR TIME ARE WE ALMOST
RAN OUT THERE TIME WE GOT THEM
TO A- DURING THE EXPANSION THIS
YEARS AGO NALCO IT HIT. THE JOB
THEY GOT THE GUN RIGHT THEY
FOUND A JOB IN HOSPITALITY
FOUND JOB AND DELIVER AND THEN.
NOW THEIR STUCK RIGHT BY I
ASSUME RIGHT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
COME BACK ON TO OUR X. THAT
CORRECT. THAT'S RIGHT. DO YOU
KNOW THE SIZE OF THAT
POPULATION. I'M PART OF THE BEN
HOWARD'S IS ADDED TO THEIR
FAMILIES RIGHT SO CHILDREN
WOULD STILL REMAIN I'M SURE YOU
KNOW THEY WOULD STILL HAVE
ACCESS TO EIGHT RIGHT- AND IF
THE CHILDREN ARE AN AGE THEY
LIKELY WOULD BE ELIGIBLE SPUR
OTHER PROGRAMS ADDRESS OFF
FRESH SO THERE THERE IS NOT
SUPPORT TO HELP ASSISTING
FAMILIES. DURING THIS TIME
SHOULD THEY HAVE EXHAUSTED
THEIR THEIR LIFETIME ON KALKA
BUT IT BUT BECAUSE THEY COULD
STILL GET SOME OTHER SERVICES
IS THERE ANYWAY FOR AND AGAIN
AT IT SYSTEMS ARE UP TO IT TO
IDENTIFY HOW LARGE THE POOL OF
PEOPLE ARE. BECAUSE THEY'RE
GETTING SOME SERVICES BUT THEY
COULDN'T GET THE OTHER ONES
RIGHT SO BECAUSE THE QUOTE
DISQUALIFYING I I'M JUST TRY TO
GET A SENSE OF. HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE SIR STUCK IN THAT. TRAP
RIGHT- SO I WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
THAT QUESTION BACK TO IN TERMS
OF THE DATA ANALYSIS PIECE. AND
SEE YOU KNOW WHAT IS- WHAT IS
READILY AVAILABLE AND LOOK I
SEE WHAT'S FEASIBLE SO WE CAN
WORK WITH YOUR STUFF. BUT I
THINK THE OTHER POINT I'D LIKE
TO MAKE IS THAT IF FOLKS ARE
STILL ELIGIBLE IF THEY'RE STILL
ON THE PROGRAM. AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT OF THE
POSITIVE FORTY EIGHT MONTHS
TIME CONTRACT IT WOULD IT WOULD
STOP THEIR TIME RIGHT SO THEY
WOULD HAVE ADDITIONAL TIME.
UNTIL WE TRANSITION TO THE
SIXTY MONTH TIME. SO THERE IS-
THAT LITTLE WIGGLE ROOM FOR
THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PERHAPS A TOWARDS THE END OF
THEIR THEIR TIME- DAY WOULD
STILL CONTINUE TO BE SEARCHED
NO AND I APPRECIATE THAT I'M
I'M JUST THINKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO- UNFORTUNATELY MIGHT
ACTUALLY- RAN OUT OF TIME
BEFORE COVERED BUT THEN. COVET
OF COURSE CHANGED. THEIR WHOLE
CONSOLE. SITUATION RIGHT AROUND
THEM SO. OKAY YEAH- ALL RIGHT
AND THEN. THE OTHER I GUESS THE
OTHER QUESTION IS THAT AND THEN
THE RACE MENTIONED- MAYBE.
PERHAPS AND I DON'T KNOW AND
REALIZE EDIE'S REALLY BUSY
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS WE NEED THEM TO DO
RIGHT NOW- BUT- ARE WE
EXPECTING PERHAPS TO SEE A- AND
YOUR PROJECTIONS FOR- CASE
RATES- DO WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
MAY BE- RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
WHETHER THROUGH P. U. A. R. ET
DE WHO THAT HIS OWN PLANE IS
ABOUT TO RUN OUT AND REASON WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THEM. GO TO CAL
WORKS AND WIDER CASELOAD IS OUT
IS BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T DID RUN
OUT THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT BUT
THEY'RE RUNNING OUT THEIR
APPOINTMENT NOW OR JUST
RECENTLY R. VERY SHORTLY AND
THEN THAT'S GOING TO CAUSE A
SUDDEN INCREASE IN OUR CASE LED
BECAUSE JUST AGAIN IS THAT AN
EXPLANATION WE LOOKED INTO. ALL
RIGHT- GREAT QUESTION SO WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH EDT
PRECISELY TO. SORT OF PARSE OUT
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE
WE RECOGNIZE. THAT UNEMPLOYMENT
IS LIKELY PUTTING INDIVIDUALS
OVER THE INCOME TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR A PROGRAM RATE- SO THAT'S
VERY REAL SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH THEM TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE PROPER MESSAGING. AND AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS DON'T GET
DROPPED. OR LOST RATE FROM
TRANSITIONING TO YOU WHY TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR TELEWORK CAL FRESHER ANY
OTHER. PROGRAMS WITHIN SOCIAL
SERVICES SO THAT WE ARE DOING-
I WOULD SAY THAT THE OTHER
PIECE IS THAT YOU KNOW IN THE
BIGGER PICTURE IS REALLY TO BE
WORKING ACROSS THESE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS. THAT'S YOUR EARLIER
POINT AROUND EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING WELL YES PERHAPS FOLKS
HAVE DROPPED OFF FROM OUR
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS PERHAPS
THEY'RE NOT- ACCESSING OUR
WELFARE TO WORK BUT WE ARE
STATE WORKFORCE SYSTEM. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS A CONTINUITY
AND THAT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
WE'RE SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO
TRANSITION FOLKS FROM OUR
PROGRAMS. INTO THEIR PROGRAM SO
THAT IS HAPPENING- I CAN'T- YOU
KNOW- I CAN'T GIVE YOU NUMBERS
RIGHT NOW BUT- AGAIN IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE MINDFUL
OF THAT'S A STRATEGY. OKAY BUT
IS A LONG TERM SO APPRECIATE
YOU ARE DOING THAT WORK AND
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT. IS THAT
BUILT IN WHAT WERE THOSE THINGS
BUILT IN INTO YOUR CASE RATE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT- YOU THAT
YOU'RE PRESENTING FOR THE
BUDGET. SO IN TERMS OF OUR-
BURKE CATHOLIC PROJECTION YES
YOU WERE GOOD POINT IN TIME
BASED ON WHAT WE EXPECTED-
THINKING THROUGH THAT FOLKS
WOULD AGAIN AFTER UNEMPLOYMENT
RAN OUT WOULD BE ABLE TO. SORT
OF TRANSITION INTO OUR OUR OUR
CASELOAD SO THAT PART WAS BUILT
INTO OKAY ALL RIGHT SO IT'S SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE IN DALLAS
WERE ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT DATA AND- EARLY
SPEED PROJECTIONS THAT WE
OBVIOUSLY DON'T KNOW WHAT. IT
DEFINITELY HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE
AND BUILT THAT THIS
POSSIBILITY. THIS SCENARIO IN
FOR TRYING TO PROJECT CASE
RATES FOR. THIS NEXT STEP
BUDGET YEAR. YES ALTHOUGH IT
WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO PREDICT
BECAUSE MANY OF THE SORT OF THE
BENEFITS IN THE RELIEF COMING
FROM THE FED EX. WIVES YOU KNOW
MAYBE FOR THREE MONTHS OR SIX
MONTHS AND IT'S SORT OF BEEN-
CHANGING AND- OUR OUR BUDGET
WAS BASED ON THE POINT. IN TIME
FRAZIER NO I UNDERSTAND AND
BELIEVE ME WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE- THE MOVING TARGET AND THAT
SOMETIMES A TARGET MOVES IN A
WAY THAT WE ACTUALLY WANTED TO
MOVE AND SOMETIMES THE OTHER
WAY BUT- BUT AND I REALIZE THAT
THIS IS- BASED ON. YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU HAD AT THE BEGINNING
THE YEAR BUT- OKAY AND
HOPEFULLY IN MAY YOU'LL PROVIDE
US WITH THE NEW PROJECTIONS AND
I JUST WANT TO GET A SENSE OF
WHAT WAS. WHAT FACTORED INTO
THAT. AND HOPEFULLY WILL ALSO
HAVE SOME MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MIGHT DO BY THEN TOO. THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL. THANK
YOU. THE YOU AS MELINDA'S HAS
OR HOW UP BUT- IF THE MISTER.
WERE YOU GONNA AND DOCTOR PANTS
QUESTION OR UNITS ON THE NEXT
POINT. YES RYAN ANDERSON WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S. I
JUST WANTED TO- MAKE A FEW HIGH
LEVEL COMMENTS ON THE-
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAPPENED SO
FAR BASED ON OUR OFFICES WHERE.
WE CAN I CAN I THE WHOLE DO
THEIR AND THAT LET CENTER
MELINDA'S AS FOR QUESTIONS
FIRST AND THEN YOU CAN. FEDERAL
ANDERS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST HAVE A QUICK ONE BECAUSE I
ON. THE CHAIR AND DR KING AND
ADDRESSED MOST OF THE ISSUES I
HAD WITH YOU WE- IT SOUNDED TO
ME LIKE THERE'S NOT OUR SYSTEM
IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO EACH
TRACK. OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
EXITED THE SYSTEM AND YOU KNOW
FIGURE OUT WHY I DIDN'T DID I
UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY. SO
IN TERMS OF OUR ACCENTS WE DO
HAVE- WHEN FOLKS EXIT THERE
NEEDS TO BE- SORT OF. ATTACKING
IF YOU WELL IN THE DATA SYSTEM
OF WHY THEY'RE EXITING AND SO
THE ITEMS THAT I CALLED OUT OR
TWO OF THE LARGEST DRIVERS-
AGAIN AND WIND THAT PERHAPS
THEY WERE OVER INCOME SO
EXCESSIVE INCOME AND THE SECOND
BEING THAT- THEY WERE EXCLUDED-
BY LAW FOR REASONS OTHER THAN
TIME LIMITS AND CITIZENSHIP
RIGHT SO MAYBE THEY DON'T.
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH- THERE WERE
DETERMINATION AND
REDETERMINATION ETCETERA SO-
THOSE ARE THE TWO LARGEST
DRIVERS CONTRIBUTING TO THE
EXIT. OKAY BUT SO DO YOU HAVE-
I MEAN IF SOMEONE. TRACKABLE
AMOUNT I YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
AROUND OF YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES
BUT I HINK- WE ALL HAVE THE
SAME CONCERN WHICH IS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE AREN'T
DROPPING OUT FOR REASONS THAT
COULD BE AVOIDED. ZACKS THAT'S
WHAT I'M WONDERING IS IT. NO IS
THERE A WAY TO KIND OF KEEP
TRACK OF THAT AND MAKE SURE
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND IF IT'S NOT A
ONE OF THE KEY REASONS YOU KNOW
THAT YOU MENTION THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SYSTEM WAS THERE
AND IS THERE ANOTHER- MEANS FOR
THEM TO. TO GET HELP THAT THEY
AREN'T AWARE OF OR IS THERE
SOMETHING ELSE GOING ON YOU
KNOW AS TO WHY THEY'RE DROPPING
OUT OF THE SYSTEM. YES YES SO-
THERE'S A FEW POSSIBLE.
SCENARIOS AYE I WOULD SUGGEST
SO- AGAIN THIS WHOLE ISSUE-
PERHAPS- FAMILIES WOULD COME IN
IF THEY HAVE BEEN TIMED OUT.
FAMILIES WOULD COME IN AND THEY
WOULD STILL CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
AID FOR THEIR CHILDREN- IN SOME
CASES WE HAVE YOU KNOW OUR HOME
VISITING PROGRAM RIGHT THAT
WE'RE PERHAPS. IF WE'RE ONLY
SERVING THE CHILDREN IN THE
FAMILY- THEY WOULD HAVE ACCESS.
TO OTHER SORT OF REFERRALS IN
IN WAYS TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES THAT THEY MAY NEED. SO
THERE IS A STCK COMPONENT AS
WELL- BUT- AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE AROUND SORT OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE TIMED
OUT. WE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE THAT
BACK AND ENSURE THAT DATA WITH
YOU I JUST I DON'T HAVE THAT
AVAILABLE. AT THIS MOMENT. OKAY
IF YOU CAN DO THAT AT SOME
POINT AND YOU SHOULD ARE. IN
THE FIVE THOUSAND ANYTHING
YOU'RE DOING. THAT WE WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT JUST JUST AS A
POINT OF REFERENCE FOR US THANK
YOU- THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT NOW
MISTER ANDERSON WITH A- THANK
YOU- I'M JUST JUST A BRING THIS
CONVERSATION BACK TO A HIGH
LEVEL WHAT'S GOING ON WITH CAL
EXCUSE THOUGH RIGHT NOW AND-
WHY OUR OFFICE THINGS THAT. THE
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS ABHORRENT
AND WORTHY OF FURTHER
EXPLORATION ALONG THESE LINES-
AS AS WE KNOW HOW WORKS OFFERS
IS HIS SENSE TO VERY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND FAMILY SO ENTER
THE PROGRAM ARE TYPICALLY. AT
THE END OF THEIR ROPES- SO
WHILE WE HAVE SEEN
TRADITIONALLY THAT CASELOAD
INCREASES IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
INCREASES ON UNEMPLOYMENT WHICH
WOULD MAKE THE CURRENT
SITUATION WHERE THE CASELOAD IS
DECLINING DESPITE UNEMPLOYMENT
UNUSUAL IT'S NOT TRADITIONALLY
BECAUSE FAMILIES COME
IMMEDIATELY TO CAL WORKS. OF
FROM LOSING THEIR JOB AND IN
FACT EVEN IN IN- TYPICAL
SITUATION WHERE A FAMILY IS
JUST RUNNING THEIR BASE- YOU I
BENEFIT THAT WOULD TYPICALLY BE
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WOULD BE
NOT INCOME ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAM. WHAT WE FIND IS
INSTEAD WHEN THERE IS A COURT.
LABOR MARKET AS THEREIS RIGHT
NOW. FOR JUST LESS LIKE TO FALL.
A JOB ONCE THEY'VE EXHAUSTED
YOU LIVE ONCE THEY'VE EXHAUSTED
THE RESOURCES OF THEIR FRIENDS
AND FAMILIES AND THEY'RE ALSO
LESS LIKELY TO FIND A JOB IF
THEY'RE ALREADY ON THE CAL
WORKS CASE THOUGH SO WE WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE. RELATIVELY FEW
ACCIDENTS DURING A TIME SUCH AS
THIS WHAT IS UNUSUAL ABOUT
RIGHT NOW ARE THESE THREE
FACTORS ADDED TOGETHER ONE THAT
APPLICATIONS ARE ANALYST WORK
WITH LOW LEVEL FOR THIS.
PROGRAM TO THAT AMONG THOSE
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE BEING
SUBMITTED THEY ARE BEING DENIED
IT AND I'M USUALLY A HIGH RATE
IS FOR HISTORICALLY AS WAS
MENTIONED BEFORE 60% AS OPPOSED
TO AROUND 48% AND NUMBER THREE
THAT EXITS ARE AT IT
HISTORICALLY HIGH RATE DESPITE
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES ARE LEAVING BECAUSE
THEY FOUND. EMPLOYMENT AND THE
FACT THAT THEY WERE ON THE
PROGRAM SUGGESTS THAT THEY
PROBABLY DID NOT HAVE A CLOSE
ENOUGH CONNECTION TO THE LABOR
MARKET BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE QUALIFIED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT. SO IT IS RATHER
MYSTERIOUS- JUST WHY THESE
THREE FACTORS ARE HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW. WE DO IN OUR IN OUR
MOST RECENT POST ON THIS GO-
MAKE SOME EFFORTS TO ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS LOOKING AT THE
DATA THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW BUT
WE THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS. WE THANK
THE DEPARTMENT FOR OFFERING THE
SOME FURTHER INSIGHT TODAY BUT
WE THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GRAPPLE
WITH EVEN MORE IN CONTINUE
ASKING THIS QUESTIONS AND
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. WITH OUR PARTNERS
AND OTHER STATES AND WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS OF FOR THE MONTHS
AHEAD. ABSOLUTELY I THINK
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE SEE THE
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE USING FOOD BANKS AND
OTHER KIND OF RESOURCES LIKE
THAT WE KNOW WE KNOW POVERTY IS
NOT POVERTY IS INCREASING. AND
YET THE POOREST OF THE POOR ARE
NOT. UTILIZING THE CAL WORKS
OUT. MY A DOCTRINE. THANK YOU
AND AGAIN TRANSACTION IF THE L.
A. AS PRESENTATION- DOES THE
OTHER HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS AS
TO- AND I KNOW THAT THE FARMS
OR SERVICE SEVENTIES OFFER TO
LOOK AT SOME THINGS- SOME
DIRECTION THAT TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT THE ANSWER TO SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS AND- WE TRIED
ENQUIRING I APPRECIATE YOUR
BACKGROUND. WE NOW IN MAY ARE
THERE THINGS WE SHOULD BE DOING
TO TRY TO FERRET OUT THE
ANSWERS TO THIS MYSTERY THIS
THREE WAY MYSTERY ACTUALLY AS
TO WHY THIS IS ALL RUNNING
COUNTERING TO WHAT WE EXPECT.
YEAH OKAY YES- IS A GREAT
QUESTION I THINK. UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE NOT AT THE POINT WHERE WE
HAVE SOLID RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
I DO THINK THAT- WE HAVE SOME
USEFUL OBSERVATIONS. FIRST
DATE. OF INCREASE IN ACCIDENTS-
IS TO BE A IN PART DRIVEN BY A
FAILURE TO COMPLETE PAPERWORK
AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE OR TO
NOT I COMPLETED CORRECTLY- IF
YOU COMBINE THIS WITH THIS
OBSERVATION THAT IN THE SPRING
WE TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED BE
DETERMINATIONS AND THAT. THAT
TEMPORARY SUSPENSION ACTUALLY
RESULT IN END THE ONLY-
INCREASE IN THE CASE OF THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED DURING. THE
PANDEMIC THAT WAS BECAUSE
VIRTUALLY NO ONE EXITED THIS
PROGRAM AS LONG AS WE WORK
REQUIRING THAT THEY SUBMIT THIS
REGULAR PAPERWORK IT DOES
SUGGEST THAT ONE POSSIBLE
OPTION HERE MIGHT BE SOMETHING
ALONG THOSE LINES OF ANOTHER
SUSPENSION OR PRE
DETERMINATIONS. NOW WE'RE NOT
QUITE AT THE POINT OF MAKING
THAT RECOMMENDATION- NOT ONLY
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A FULL
ANSWER TO THIS MYSTERY BUT ALSO
BECAUSE IT'S WHAT JUST AGREE
AND LEGALLY COMPLICATED
UNFORTUNATELY THIS RETURN
NATION PAPERWORK IS LINKED TO
THAT ACCOUNT FRESH WHICH HAS
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. SO WITH
WITHOUT HAVING A FEDERAL WAIVER
THE CALFRESH SIDE IT MIGHT BE
COMPLICATED SAID THINK ABOUT
HOW YOU DECOUPLE BUT THAT WOULD
BE ONE. A POSSIBLE OPTION WE
ALSO THINK EXPLORING ADDITIONAL
AREAS WHERE. IN PERSON
REQUIREMENTS OR OR SOMETHING OR
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES
SOMETHING- DEBTS IN THE
APPLICATION OR ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION PROCESS THAT
MIGHT BE PARTICULARLY
COMPLICATED BECAUSE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS RIGHT NOW THIS
IMPORTANT WE UNDERSTAND THE
DEPARTMENTS. CURRENTLY CRAFTING
OF FURTHER GUIDANCE ON IN
PERSON PHOTO ID REQUIREMENTS
FOR THAT WE THINK THAT'S THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN FURTHER
IDENTIFYING ANYTHING ALONG
THOSE LINES- AND OTHER THINGS
WE COULD LOOK AT BE. FOR
EXAMPLE EXEMPTING- YOU WIPE
BENEFITS OR ANY FEDERAL. EIGHT
BENEFITS FROM INCOME
CALCULATIONS JUST MAKING A
CLEAR LINE THAT THOSE WOULD NOT
RENDER ANYONE IS INELIGIBLE
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
ALSO WORTH LOOKING INTO. OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. OKAY A DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ANYTHING. NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD COMMITTEE CHAIR
THANK YOU. OKAY MISTER TENDER'S.
THANK YOU I'M SO GOING ON THE
THIRD ITEM HERE. IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO
DO- TO ENSURE THAT ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES WERE CONTINUE TO BE
SERVED BY THE CALVERTS PROGRAM
DURING THIS CRISIS- SOME SORT
OF GOING BACK TO MARCH OF LAST
YEAR ACROSS OUR PROGRAMS WE
REALLY DID TRY TO BE PROACTIVE-
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
SUPPORTING OUR COUNTIES. TO
PROVIDE REMOTE ACCESS TO
SERVICES AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
RIGHT- EXAMPLES SUCH AS A LEAD
AND OTHERS- ALSO DURING THIS
TIME WE WERE ABLE TO RELEASED
GUIDANCE TO HELP ALLEVIATE AND
ADDRESS THE ISSUES- SOME OF
WHICH ARE RUNING FROM ILLEGAL
CALLED OUT AND THEY REALLY
PROVIDED FLEXIBILITIES ABOUT
WERE CENTERED AROUND KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE- AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY WERE SUPPORTED
THROUGH THIS CRISIS SO FOR
INSTANCE. THE FORTY EIGHT MONTH
ON TIME CLOCK PIES- WE ALSO
CREATE GOOD FOR WELFARE WORK-
AND WE UTILIZE COULD CAUSE TO
CURE SANCTIONS WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE ALSO WERE ABLE TO USE
FLEXIBILITY SUCH AS
DISREGARDING RECIPIENTS ONE
TIME COVERED RELIEF PAYMENTS-
OR THE STIMULUS PAYMENTS RATE-
AS INCOME FOR. LEGIBILITY
PURPOSES AND SO THAT MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS WEREN'T HURT BY THAT
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME INCOME-
ASIDE FROM THAT THOUGH WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
PRIDE- TARGETED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SUPPORTER
COUNTIES- OBVIOUSLY IN IN
PIVOTING AND PROVIDING-
SERVICES IN IN THE- ONSET OF
COPING WITH CHALLENGING- JUST
TRANSITIONING TO A REMOTE
WORKFORCE RIGHT AND THEN IT WAS
YOU KNOW COUNTIES FINDING
THEMSELVES IN VARIOUS STAGES OF
THE BLUEPRINT FOR SAFE.
CONDAMINE AND HAVING TO ADJUST
ACCORDINGLY- THROUGHOUT THIS
WHOLE PROCESS- WE CONTINUE TO
DO OUR MANAGEMENT EVALUATIONS
AND IN PARTICULAR ON THE
CALFRESH SIDE THIS IS BEEN
REALLY CRITICAL BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY BEEN- IMPORTANT
INFORMATIVE FOR US TO HELP
IDENTIFY AREAS. WHERE WE NEED
TO HELP SUPPORT COUNTIES- REYES
CHILD. SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
BETTER. ASSISTANCE LATER IN THE
YEAR IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR
WE WERE ABLE TO REDUCE RELEASE
FURTHER GUIDANCE THAT- AGAIN
REITERATED THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING THAT WE PROVIDE IN
PERSON ACCESS. TO COUNTY
OFFICES RIGHT IN INTO OUR
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT REALLY-
ENCOURAGING AND PUSHING THE
NEED TO. CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
ONLINE ACCESS TO APPLICATIONS
AND FORMS ETCETERA ALONG WITH
TELEPHONIC ASSISTANCE AND SO
COLLECTIVELY- THAT HAS REALLY
HELPED MAKE SURE THAT
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER A PERSON.
IS COMING IN IN IN PERSON TO
SEEK SERVICES AND PERHAPS HAS
TO MAKE AN APPOINTMENT OR
WHETHER THEY'RE CALLING IN THAT
THERE IS A WAY. FOR THEM TO
RECEIVE INFORMATION THAT THEY
NEED- TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
THEIR THEIR- SUPPORT- LASTLY I
WOULD SAY THAT MORE ASSERTIVE
COMPREHENSIVELY- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO IDENTIFY A GROUP OF. OF
STAFF WITHIN OUR PROGRAMS- THAT
ARE JOINTLY WORKING TOGETHER TO
DRAFT GUIDANCE PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
SITUATION. TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
THINGS ARE EVOLVING- THAT WE
CAN QUICKLY RESPOND AND. AND
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
COMING UP ANY QUESTIONS AROUND
THAT. NOW I THINK WE'RE I THINK
WE'RE ALL AT STRUCK BY THE
CHALLENGE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE WATCHING THIS AND HOPE TO
HEAR. MORE AS WE GO FORWARD.
ANYTHING ELSE AND APART A
FINANCIAL L. A. O. ON THIS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON. BUT THE FOR
THAT THANK YOU OKAY. THEN ISSUE
NUMBER TWO COLOR GRANT
INCREASES. GOOD AFTERNOON RUN
HOUSE OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO ISSUE
TO RELATED TO THE PROPOSED CAL
WORKS GRANT INCREASE SO TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF SUMMARY OF THE
PROPOSAL UNDER CURRENT STATUTE
A MECHANISM EXISTS SUCH THAT
CAL WORKS GRANT INCREASES WILL
BE PROVIDED OCTOBER FIRST TO
THE EXTENT THERE'S NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT IS
AVAILABLE AFTER RECOVERING
COSTA. PRIOR GRANT INCREASES
AND THE REPEAL THE MAXIMUM
FAMILY GRANT ROLE IN YEARS WERE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
REVENUE REVENUE IS INSUFFICIENT
TO COVER PREVIOUS- MAXIMUM
FAMILY GRANT RULES OR A GRAND
CROSS COST THE GENERAL FUND IS
REQUIRED TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE. AS OF THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET NINETEEN NINETY ONE REAR
REVENUE PROJECTIONS INDICATE
THERE WILL BE ABOUT FIFTY POINT
ONE MILLION AND REVENUE
REALIGNMENT REVENUE AVAILABLE
TO PROVIDE A ONE POINT 5% GRANT
INCREASE STARTING IN OCTOBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIS
INCREASE WILL BRING THE MAXIMUM
A PAYMENT OR GROUND LEVEL TO
EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY ONE
DOLLARS PER MONTH FOR AN
ASSISTANCE UNIT. OF THREE
RESIDING IN HIGH COUNTY WHICH
IS FORTY PERCENT. OF THE SHARE
OF THE F. P. L. IN SUMMARY THE
STATUTORY MECHANISM TO INCREASE
CAO WORKS GRANTS EXISTS TO
SERVE AS A MEANS TO PROVIDE FOR
GRANT INCREASES IN TIMES WHEN-
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
REVENUE. ARE PROJECTING ABOVE
GRANT CAUGHT FIRE GRANT COST
AND THE MAXIMUM FAMILY GRANT
ROLE. THAT'S A BRIEF SUMMARY OF
THE PROPOSAL AND HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. I DON'T HAVE ANY
MANAGEMENT DEPARTMENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
PRESENTATION I APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED TO WORK ON- TRYING AT
LEAST. BE SURE THAT- NO CALCIUM
LEASE I MEAN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE POVERTY 50% SOME
PRETTY LOW BAR BUT I GUESS IT'S
AT LEAST WE'RE TRYING TO GET
THAT FAR. AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK- THE IDEA OF A QUESTIONS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT FROM THIS BUT
SINCE- THAT IS ABOUT SOMETHING
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT ON GOING
BASIS RELATED TO CAO WORKS- AND
MAYBE YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE I
ANSWERED THIS QUESTION BUT- IN
TERMS OF I KNOW WHEN THINGS
WE'VE WORKED ON IN THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE AND- TO ENSURE
THAT WE MAINTAIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
SERVE- OF PEOPLE WHO NEED CAL
WORKS AND OTHER SERVICES-
ESPECIALLY WHEN RECESSION HITS
AND- WE HAVE AN UPPER.
INCREASING CASES WHICH I GUESS
WE HAVEN'T QUITE SEEN YET BUT
WE MAY SEE- WAS THE- SINGLE
ALLOCATION FORMULA AND I KNOW
THAT- THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SO WE CERTAINLY WHEN
I WAS CHAIR AND COMING UP TO
THE FINAL AGREEMENT FOR A MORE
REASONABLE FORMULA. SO I JUST
WANNA PUT A PIN ON THAT MAYBE
SOMEONE CAN GET BACK ON THE MAY
REVISE ON ON PROGRESS I
UNDERSTAND JUST CONTINUING
PROGRESS ON THAT AND HOPEFULLY
THERE IS CLOSE TO A FINAL
AGREEMENT- AFTER MANY YEARS BUT
I DID WANT TO SIR MENTIONED
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT- THIS IS
A PAST CHAIR JUST WANNA BE SURE
THAT WERE- CONTINUE MAKE
PROGRESS ON THAT TO BE SURE
THAT- WE CAN MAINTAIN THE
COUNTY INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY
TO SERVE. THE PEOPLE WHEN
ESPECIALLY THIS ONE CASELOADS
ARE FLUCTUATING UP AND DOWN SO
I JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT-
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
WORK TO BE SURE THAT- WE CAN
TRY TO AT LEAST AT THIS MINIMUM
AND HOPEFULLY. WHEN TIMES ARE
BETTER WE CAN MAYBE EVEN. SAYS
SLIGHTLY HIGHER BAR. FOR
FAMILIES WHO ARE DESPERATELY IN
NEED SO THANK. YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR HISTORICAL.
TALK OKAY. OKAY HELLO ANYTHING.
NO NOT ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU
OKAY. SHE WENT OVER. NEXT WE
HAVE OUR CALFRESH ITEMS AND
ALEXIS FERNANDEZ WILL BE
COVERING THOSE. EIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU JENNIFER AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE TEAM
MEETING YOU FOR HAVING ME HI MY
NAME'S ALEXIS FERNANDEZ AND I
AM THE CHIEF OF THE CALIBRATION
NUTRITION BRANCH OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
WE OVERSEE THE ADMISSION THE
ADMINISTRATION OF SEVEN FEDERAL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS INCLUDING
CALFRESH I'M GONNA START JUST
RIGHT AHEAD ON THIS FIRST ISSUE
AROUND OUR- CAL FRESHCO
RESPONSE. PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
THAT CALIFORNIA'S CASELOAD GREW
SIGNIFICANTLY WITH THE
EXPANSION OF CALFRESH SSI
RECIPIENTS ARE MOST RECENTLY
AVAILABLE DEBT DATA FOR
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY SHOW
THAT WE ARE NOW SERVING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND SSI RECIPIENTS. AS KEN
MENTIONED- THAT BRINGS OUR
TOTAL OLDER ADULTS SERVED TO
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND- MORE THAN 1100%
INCREASE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. DURING THE PANDEMIC
SO THE COMING OFF OF THAT
CASELOAD INCREASED OUR TOTAL
CASELOAD PEAKED DURING JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY I JUST OVER FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION
INDIVIDUALS. AND IN DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY THE MOST RECENTLY
AVAILABLE- MONTH FOR WHICH
THERE IS DATA. COVERAGE
PROVIDED THROUGH BENEFITS TO
JUST OVER FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION INDIVIDUALS. INSURE
ACCESS TO FOOD WELL BENEFIT
RETENTION AND ADDRESS A BENEFIT
ADEQUACY OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FEDERAL
OPTIONS IN ADMINISTRATIVE OF
FLEXIBILITIES BECOME FERMENTED
SEVEN ADMINISTRATIVE WAIVERS
RANGING FROM REPORTING
FLEXIBILITIES WHICH WERE
TOUCHED ON TO WAIVERS OF THE
INTERVIEW REQUIREMENT. TO
ADDRESS BENEFIT ADEQUACY WE'VE
ISSUED EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO THROUGH
THE LENGTH OF THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY AMER TO SEE A LOT
MEANS BRING EVERY CALFRESH
HOUSEHOLD TO THE MAXIMUM
ALLOTMENT BASED ON HOUSEHOLD
SIZE SO AS AN EXAMPLE A
HOUSEHOLD OF THREE IS CURRENTLY
RECEIVING A FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH AND THAT'S
EVERY HOUSEHOLD OF THREE
RECEIVING CALFRESH SO OVER THE
LAST EIGHT MONTHS THE
SETTLEMENTS REPRESENT NEARLY
TWO POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL. FOOD BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIANS. IN APRIL WE WERE
THE FOR IT TAKES THE IMPROVE.
OF EDT ONLINE. WE WATCHED WITH
TO RETAILERS AND JUST RECENTLY
IN NOVEMBER EXPANDED TASK
ALBERTSONS AND SAFEWAY ON
BONDS- THEY ARE GOING FULLY
ONLINE EARLY THIS YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE ALSO DESIGNED
AND IMPLEMENTED THE FIRST EVER
PANDEMIC TV T. PROGRAM PDT
PROVIDES THE BENEFITS TO
CHILDREN WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FREE OR REDUCED PRICE MEALS BUT
MAY NOT HAVE READY ACCESS TO
THOSE MEALS BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY. I'LL BE
TWEEN APRIL SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY WE OPERATED WHAT WE'RE
NOW CALLING A PANDEMIC AB T.
ONE POINT OH THE ORIGINAL P.
ETT PROGRAM- AND THE GREAT
MAJORITY FAMILIES RECEIVED A
STANDARD BENEFIT. OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER CHILD. BY LATE
SEPTEMBER WE WRAPPED UP- THE
PROGRAM HAVING ISSUED PT
REFERENCE TO OVER THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION CHILDREN.
TOTALING NEARLY ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN FOOD
BENEFITS. AND LATE SEPTEMBER WE
WERE APPROVED TO ISSUE AN
EXTENSION ON THOSE BENEFITS TO
CHILDREN WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED FOR PD TEAM- WE JUST
WRAPPED UP ISSUING THOSE
ADDITIONAL PDT BENEFITS. TO
JUST OVER THREE POINT THREE
MILLION CHILDREN A TOTALING
NEARLY SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FOOD
BENEFITS. LET ME ALSO SPEAK TO
THE RECENT RELIEF PACKAGE
AUTHORIZED IN DECEMBER AS WAS
REQUESTED IN THE AGENDA. JUST
THIS WEEK WE IMPLEMENTED A 15%
INCREASE IN CALFRESH BENEFITS
SO THIS IS IN ADDITION TO
EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS. AND IS
PROVIDED TO ALL GOLFERS
HOUSEHOLDS SO AS AN EXAMPLE
THIS BRINGS OF THE MAXIMUM
BENEFIT. FOR A FAMILY OF THREE
FROM FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH TO SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN DOLLARS A MONTH AN
EIGHTY ONE DOLLAR INCREASE
QUITE SIGNIFICANT- THIS IS
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED THROUGH
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE THOUGH-
WE BELIEVE THERE WILL BE ACTION
FEDERALLY TO EXTEND THIS-
BEYOND A JUNE TWENTY ONE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ISSUED GUIDANCE
AND WORK WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS TO EXCLUDE THE FEDERAL
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT. UP
BENEFIT BOOST OR THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A WEEK INCREASE
I WOULDN'T DETERMINING CAL
FRESH INCOME ELIGIBILITY. AND
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE WE
SAW LAST YEAR THAT THE
ADDITIONAL YOU ARE BE PAYMENTS
MADE MANY APPLICANT HOUSEHOLDS
IN ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH EVEN
THOUGH FOOD BENEFITS WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED AN ESSENTIAL SAFETY
NET RESOURCE. BUT WE ARE VERY
EXCITED TO SEE THAT WE ARE NOW
ABLE TO EXCLUDE THAT AND THAT
WILL BE EXCLUDED AT LEAST FOR
THE NEXT NINE MONTHS SO IF
THOSE BENEFITS ARE ETENDED-
WOULD STILL NOT BE CONSIDERED
FOR CALIFORNIA PURPOSES. LAST
WEEK ALL HIGHLIGHT TEMPORARY
CHANGES TO OUR STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY RULES ALSO
IMPLEMENTED AS A RESULT OF THE
RELIEF ACT. WELL WE RECENTLY
LAUNCHED AN EFFORT TO ROLL OUT
THESE CHANGES RATHER QUICKLY TO
INFORM NEWLY ELIGIBLE
HOUSEHOLDS AND TO FACILITATE
THEIR APPLICATION. IT EXTENDS A
LIABILITY TO TWO LARGE GROUPS
OF STUDENTS. OTHERS WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR WORK STUDY AND
THOSE WHO HAVE AN EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION OF ZERO
DOLLARS. WE ESTIMATE FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT HAVE
THAT ZERO DOLLAR EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION. AND AT
LEAST A HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR WORK
STUDY. ALTHOUGH THERE IS SOME
OVERLAP BUT STILL VERY LARGE
GROUPS OF NEWLY ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS. THOUGH YOU CHANGE
WILL BE IN EFFECT AT LEAST
THROUGH THE END OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY THIRTY DAYS
AFTER TO BE EXACT- AND WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF MAJOR OUTREACH
EFFORTS ALREADY UNDER WAY THEY
STARTED. YESTERDAY INSTANTLY.
WE ARE WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO CONDUCT OUTREACH
TO ALL THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
ZERO DOLLAR ESE STUDENTS AND
WORK WORKING WITH OR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. OTHER THREE PUBLIC
STATEMENTS TO CONDUCT
ELIGIBILITY TO WORK STUDY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS RECEIVE ME
CONDUCT OUTREACH TO WORK STUDY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. AND BECAUSE
RUSSIA IS NOT AVAILABLE TO
EVERY CALIFORNIAN OFF ALSO
HIGHLIGHT OUR WORK DISTRIBUTING
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDED
EMERGENCY FOOD BENEFITS. ALSO
THIS IS FOOD DISTRIBUTED
THROUGH OUR NETWORK OF FOOD
BANKS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
ADDITION TO ADMINISTERING THE
FEDERAL FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS. I WOULD HAVE RECEIVED
A SIGNIFICANT BOOST IN FUNDING
BY EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF
JUST THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WILL
HAVE A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
DISTRIBUTED AT A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FOOD FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN DIAPERS AND WILL
HAVE PROVIDED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN REIMBURSEMENT. FOR
CLOSELY RELATED FOOD EXPENSES
MUCH OF THIS STATE FUNDED- AS A
RESULT OF ADMINISTRATIVE AND
LEGISLATIVE ACTION. ON AVERAGE
WERE DISTRIBUTING A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND TWO BOXES A
MONTH AND WE ESTIMATE- WITH
CURRENT. ARE SUPPLIED WE WILL
BE ABLE TO DO SO THROUGH APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. LET ME WRAP
UP BY SPEAKING ABOUT WHAT'S
COMING NEXT AND I KNOW THIS IS
QUITE A LOT BUT- AS WE
HIGHLIGHTED IN TODAY'S AGENDA
THE PANDEMIC HAS IMPACTED THE
RATE OF FOOD INSECURITY
EXPERIENCED BY CALIFORNIANS.
WITH CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED MORE THAN OTHERS. IT'S
ONLY TOUCH ON SOME OF OUR
EFFORTS IN THE COMING MONTHS.
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING AN
EXPANDED PDT PROGRAM TO SERVE
FAMILIES WITH BOTH SCHOOL AGE
AND YOUNG CHILDREN. THIS IS AN
EXPANSION OF THE PREVIOUS
PROGRAM AND WE ANTICIPATE
REACHING AS MANY AS FIVE
MILLION CHILDREN STATEWIDE. THE
CRITICAL BENEFITS- FOR THE
ENTIRE SCHOOL YEAR AVAILABLE
FOR THE ENTIRE SCHOOL YEAR MORE
THAN A HUNDRED DOLLARS-
ESTIMATED PER MONTH IN INCLUDE
BENEFITS FOR THESE CHILDREN.
WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
REACHING AND SUPPORTING A
BENEFIT RETENTION AMONG OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. AS AN EXAMPLE WE
RECENTLY APPLIED FOR AND WERE
APPROVED TO WAIVE OR ELIMINATE
THE STAR SEVEN WHICH IS OUR
PERIODIC REPORTS IN BETWEEN
APPLICATION RECERTIFICATION YOU
HAVE TO SUBMIT A REPORT. WE
WERE APPROVED TO WAIVE THAT FOR
HOUSEHOLDS WITH ELDERLY AND
DISABLED HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS AND
NO EARNED INCOME. WE'RE
ATTRACTED IMPLEMENTED EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND EXPECT
THE CHANGE. WOULD IMPACT OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS A MAJOR STRIDE
TOWARD BENEFIT RETENTION. WE'RE
INVESTING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
AND OUTREACH IN ADDITION TO OUR
ONGOING WORK- FOR EXAMPLE
REACHING OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES STUDENTS ARE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN AIMS TO SERVE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS. SO
PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE NEVER
ENGAGE WITH CALFRESH BEFORE BUT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY MIGHT NOW FIND
THEMSELVES ELIGIBLE FOR EXAMPLE
ANTICIPATED JOB LOSS. WE'RE
GOING DIFFERENT METHODS TO
REACH THEM SO AS AN EXAMPLE
WE'RE SHIFTING INTO STREAMING
MEDIA SERVICES TO TARGET
AVERAGE BASED ON DEMOGRAPHICS
AND EVIDENCE BASED RESEARCH
AGAIN WITH THAT NEWLY ELIGIBLE
POPULATION IN MIND. WE'RE ALSO
EXPANDING OUR CAPACITY FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS
JENNIFER MENTIONED WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING CLIENT ACCESS A
SUPPORTING OUR WORK FORCE AS
THEY PREPARE TO TRANSITION TO.
HOPEFULLY POST PANDEMIC
OPERATIONS AND INCREASING THE
EFFICIENCIES OF OUR
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO EFFECTIVELY MEET
DEMAND. JENNIFER ALSO TOUCHED
ON IN THE AREA OF EMPLOYMENT
AND TRAINING- THE MOVE TO
REMOTE SERVICES WE'VE ALSO
RECENTLY EXPANDED- THE
AVAILABILITY OF STATEWIDE
PROVIDERS OF EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING SERVICES SO AGAIN OF
PREPARING FOR THAT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. AND THE NEED FOR WORK
FOR SERVICES. AND LASTLY WE
REMAIN FOCUSED ON ENSURING THE
CAPACITY TO CONTINUE
DISTRIBUTING EMERGENCY FOOD
ESPECIALLY AS ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDS MAY BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR
THIS PURPOSE. SO LET ME STOP
THERE- AND SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS I KNOW THAT WAS QUITE
A BIT OF INFORMATION. THAT IS
THAT WAS A LOT OF INFORMATION-
BUT WITH THE P. D. B. T. ARM.
HAVE WE ARRANGE IT NOW SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN USE USES ONLINE AS
WARDEN HAVE FOOD DELIVERED TO
THEM FOR THOSE WHO MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO DRIVE I KNOW THERE WAS
AN ISSUE WITH THAT BEFORE WE
RESOLVE THAT. YES SO BOTH ARE
REGULAR CAL FRESH BENEFITS B.
AND R. P. ET T. BENEFITS CAN BE
USED ONLINE. RIGHT NOW. WE ARE
APPROVED- IN THREE RETAILERS SO
RETAILERS MUST BE APPROVED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. OR WERE
OPERATING AND AMAZON WALMART
AND THEN THAT. ALBERTSONS MANLY
OF BRANDS IF YOU WILL WHICH
INCLUDES BONDS AND SAFE WAYS.
SO WE PUT OKAY- AND THEN MY
OTHER QUESTION WAS JUST AROUND.
ED WE HAVE SOME OF THE LOWEST
RATES OF PEOPLE SIGNING UP IN
THE COUNTRY AND YET WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST RATE OF POVERTY. DO YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU'RE OUTRAGE GONNA.
ADDRESS THAT I'M AND I DIDN'T
HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT THE
IMMIGRANT POPULATION JUST AS AS
IT RELATES TO HUNGER. AND FOOD
INSECURITY. SO THAT IS THE GOAL
OF OUR OUTREACH AND I WOULD SAY
IT'S TO PROBLEMS SO IT'S OUT OF
REACH INTENDED TO. ENCOURAGE
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS TO APPLY
AS A SPOKE A BIT TO SOME OF
OUR- TARGET POPULATIONS IN THAT
WORK AND RIGHTFULLY- GOING
INTO. TWENTY TWENTY ONE UNDER
THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION AND
POSSIBLY SOME NEW MESSAGING
AROUND. ELIGIBILITY AMONG. A
NON CITIZENS OR THEIR CITIZEN
FAMILY MEMBERS SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS ON OUR RADAR
WE SOLVED IT THERE WERE. A
CHILLING EFFECT IF YOU WILL AS
A RESULT OF SOME OF THE ACTIONS
THAT THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION HAD TAKEN SO ARE
OUT OF REACH OUT PLANS DO
INCORPORATE THOSE UP GROUPS AND
MAKING SURE THEY- I PERSONALLY
CALPERS IS AVAILABLE BUT WE'RE
ALSO TAKING STRIDES AROUND
BENEFIT RETENTION. WHICH IS
QUITE IMPORTANT SO I SPOKE TO
THE WORK AROUND OLDER ADULTS
AND MAKING SURE THAT ONCE
THEY'RE ON THE PROGRAM WE CAN
KEEP THOSE CASES FOR AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE SO AS AN EXAMPLE
UNDER- FEDERAL WAIVER THE
ELDERLY SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION
PROJECT WE ARE ABLE. TO PROVIDE
A THIRTY SIX MONTH
CERTIFICATION PERIOD WE WILL
NOW NOT REQUIRE THAT NEED
REPORT SAYS THIRTY SIX MONTHS
VERY STABLE CIRCUMSTANCES. SO
IT IS A MIX OF BOTH-THE OUT
REACH UP FRONT FOR APPLICATION.
AND THEN THE BENEFIT RETENTION
WORK. AND NOW I'M NEW TO THIS
BUT UNDERSTAND A FEDERAL
APPLICATION THAT MAKES THE
PROCESS A LITTLE BIT EASIER TO
SIGN UP FOR CALFRESH AND OURS
IS A LITTLE BIT MORE CUMBERSOME
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT. ABOUT
WHY WE HAVE ADOPTED THE- SO.
I'M NOT SURE WHICH- FEDERAL
APPLICATION YOUR SEATS- THANK
YOU- WE ARE APPLICATION
REFLECTS FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
WE DO HAVE A CALFRESH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE TOOL GET
CALFRESH SHOPWORN IT CAN BE
COMPLETED IN ABOUT TEN MINUTES
WE HAVE SOME DEDICATED VERSIONS
SO WE HAVE A VERSION DEDICATED
FOR STUDENTS- WE HAVE ANOTHER
TOOL THAT ARE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION PARTNERS USE SO
THERE IS A SHORT. FORM OF THE
ONLINE APPLICATION NOW THAT I
THINK OF IT I THINK YOU MAY BE
REFERRING TO THAT PAPE THE
SHORTENED PAPER APPLICATION FOR
OLDER ADULTS IS THAT- GIVE STOP.
YES YES SO- THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'VE LOOKED AT AS PART OF OUR
E. SAP WORK OF THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS WE DID PRIORITIZE THE
WAIVER OF THE SAR SEVEN WHICH
IS THE MID. REPORT AS WELL AS
THE EXTENDED CERTIFICATION
PERIODS- AND I THINK WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT OTHER OPTIONS OVER
TIME AS WELL. ESPECIALLY OUR
OLDER ADULTS AND OUR OLDER
WOMEN THAT WE KNOW HAVE BEEN
ESPECIALLY HARD HIT. IN THIS.
DOCUMENT. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION- I
GUESS SO YOU KNOW IT BEGAN TO
PREACH IT TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT- WE'RE- THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO SPECIALLY THIS
TREMENDOUS TIME OF TIME OF
NEED. YES THE QUESTION IS THAT-
WELL. HOW WE MEASURING WHETHER
THIS IS ENOUGH I GUESS IS- AND-
SO- AND I KNOW THAT THAT THAT
CARES REYES REFERRED TO THE
FACT OF WE LOOKING AND I'LL IN
PASSED COMPARISONS WITH OTHER
STATES WE HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
AND GETTING PEOPLE ENROLLED
INTO CALFRESH- SO HOW NOW WITH
COVERT HOW. DOING AGAIN AND
PERHAPS IN COMPARISON TO SOME
OF OUR OTHER STATES I KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGER IT'S MORE
DIVERSE GEOGRAPHICALLY IN MANY
OTHER WAYS. BUT EARLY CLOSING
IN ON HOW OTHER STATES ARE
DOING A GIVEN SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING- SO
IT'S NOT EVERYTHING'S ABOUT
COMPARISONS BUT- PERHAPS- CAN
YOU CAN YU SPEAK TO THAT. IN
TERMS OF- OUR ABILITY TO SERVE
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO NEED AT WHO
NEED IT SO CERTAINLY I KNOW
THAT SUDDENLY CAL ONLY CERTAIN
PEOPLE GET CALFRESH AND THAT'S
WHY WE ALSO FUND FOOD BANKS
BECAUSE FOOD BANKS ARE CUTTING
OTHER PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO DON'T
MISS NOT ALL YUP NOT ALWAYS
PEOPLE CAN'T QUALIFY FOR
CALFRESH BUT CERTAINLY A GOOD
PORTION OF THOSE CONCERNED THAT
WAY SO IT'S A MULTI PRONGED
STRATEGY. BUT JUST SORT OF.
THINK STEPPING BACK- IS THERE
SOME METRIC A GAUGE THAT WE'RE
SAYING THAT WE HAVE TO TRY TO
SEE HOW WELL WE'RE ACTUALLY
MEETING TO TOTAL THE- YES. SO
WE HAVE A CALFRESH DATA
DASHBOARD ONLINE WITH- THE MOST
RECENT KIND OF CASE LAW DATA
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA FOR OUR
PROGRAM- AS WELL YOU'LL SEE A
FEW MEASURES OF PARTICIPATION.
WE HAVE. A NEW PARTICIPATION
RATE HAS NOT BEEN RELEASED
NATIONALLY SINCE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED SO. UNABLE TO THROUGH
THE LINK OUR PARTICIPATION RATE
TO THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE AND
USUALLY THAT DATA IS
UNFORTUNATELY A COUPLE YEARS
BEHIND. SO WE HAVE YET TO EVEN
SEE THE NEW PARTICIPATION
NUMBERS AFTER- WE EXPANDED CAL
FIRST SS I RECIPIENTS ARE
HAVING WATCHED SOME OF OUR
BROADER OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. IN
TERMS OF THAT NATIONAL TRENDS
AS- JENNIFER MENTIONED THE DATA
A BIT BEHIND ON THE NATIONAL
LEVEL. BUT WE ARE SEEING- THAT
STATES ARE A LITTLE BIT ALL
OVER THE PLACE SOME SEEING AS
HE STILL GAINES ON PAR WITH
WHAT CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED
REALLY ON OTHERS SEEING
DECLINES. AND JUST TO GIVE YOU
A SENSE OF THE PRELIMINARY
NUMBERS. WHEN COMPARING
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TO
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY THE
CHANGING CALIFORNIA WAS POINT
4% IN OUR CASE OR IN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE WAS 1% SO NOT
FAR BEHIND THAT NATIONAL
AVERAGE JUST ON THESE VERY
PRELIMINARY NUMBERS WHICH WE
KEEP AN EYE ON- TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WHAT KIND OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THAT
NATIONAL TREND AND THAT WOULD
BE THE BEST AVAILABLE RIGHT IN
THE MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC OKAY.
I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER HAS
ALSO APPRECIATE THE CHALLENGES
AND WE HAVE TAKEN MANY STEPS TO
ACTUALLY MAKE CALFRESH MORE
AVAILABLE TO LARGER POPULATIONS
HE'S POINTED OUT WITH FAMILY
AND IT'S ABLE TO MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO- PEOPLE ON SSI AND
SO FORTH SO- MAYBE IT SPEAKS TO
A- OF. AND AGAIN IT WOULD BE A
STATE ONLY BUT- PERHAPS THE
NATIONAL EFFORT TO FIND WAYS TO
GET. SOME BETTER DATA MORE
UPDATED AT TWO TWO PLUS YEAR
LOOK BACK. AT TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE WE'RE STANDING THANK YOU.
AND JUST TO VISIT ONE MORE TIME
THE ISSUE AROUND FOOD BANKS AND
WE KNOW THAT WE'VE SEEN SUCH AN
INCREASE IN OUR FOOD BANK SO WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE HUNGRY OUT
THERE. WE HAVE LOWER RATES OF
PEOPLE UP ON CALFRESH SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A DISCONNECT
IN THERE SOMEWHERE THAT WE'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO TOUCH. THANK
YOU. OKAY. RIGHT ANYTHING FROM
L. L. NO THANK YOU OKAY NOTHING
ELSE NOT DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I
THINK FOR THAT THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WANT
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. OKAY SO I
WILL TAKE THAT ONE AS WELL. SO
AS DESCRIBED IN OUR HEARING
AGENDA- AND THIS IS RELATED TO
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
BENEFITS AND TRANSITION
NUTRITION BENEFIT PROGRAMS-
THESE TWO PROGRAMS SNB AND TMB
FOR SHORT WERE IMPLEMENTED WITH
THE EXPANSION OF CALFRESH TO
SSI RECIPIENTS. THEY WERE
INTENDED TO MITIGATE THE HARM
OF THEPOLICY CHANGE ON
EXISTING CALFRESH HOUSEHOLDS
WHO WHEN THE CHANGE WAS
IMPLEMENTED EITHER AT. A LOSS
IN CALFRESH BENEFITS OR BECAME
AN ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH
BENEFITS. SO BENEFITS FROM BOTH
THE SMB AND TMB PROGRAMS ARE
ISSUED BASED ON A BENEFIT TABLE
AND ORIGINALLY THAT BENEFIT
TABLE WAS BASED ARE USING IT
STILL IS BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
SSR RECIPIENTS IN THE HOUSEHOLD
AT THE TIME THAT THE POLICY
CHANGE WAS IMPLEMENTED. SO THE
PROPOSAL TO UPDATE THE SMB AND
TMB BENEFIT TABLES ARE WERE
CALCULATED USING DATA FOR ON
ARTS SARS OR STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED RECONCILIATION SYSTEM
PAIN MOUTHFUL THAT IT'S OUR
ACTUAL EDT DATA. AND SO WHAT WE
DID IS WE ANALYZE EACH CATEGORY
IN THE BENEFIT TABLE. HE AND
POST THE EXPANSION OF CALFRESH
TO DETERMINE IF WE HAD BEEN
CHIEF OUR INTENDED GOAL. OF
THEM WE BALANCE EACH CATEGORY
INDIVIDUALLY SO AT LEAST 50% OF
RECIPIENTS X. THAT- EXPERIENCED
EITHER NO CHANGE OR INCREASE IN
BENEFITS WHEN YOU COMBINE THEIR
PREVIOUS CALFRESH AND SMB OR
THEIR NEW TMB- BENEFITS. SO
THAT THE 50% THRESHOLD ALL ADD
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT
OF MITIGATING THE LOSS OF
BENEFITS FOR THE CASELOAD AND
SO THESE BENEFITS UPDATES- PART
TO. GET MORE ACCURATE IF YOU
WILL WITH THE LOSS OF
CALIFORNIA SHE- THAT HAPPENED
AT THE TIME OF THE POLICY
CHANGE AND I'M GONNA STOP HERE
BECAUSE THEY REALIZE THAT WAS
QUITE COMPLICATED I'LL MISS IT
THERE ANY QUESTIONS. I WOULD
JUST COMIDAS ON WHO'S INVOLVED
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS-
THOSE ARE TWO PRETTY GOOD
EXPLANATION THANK. OKAY PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY SO WITH REGARD TO
THE REPLACEMENT OF SM BEER TMB
BENEFITS- WOULDN'T FOOD THAT IS
PURCHASED WITH THOSE BENEFITS
IS LOST YOU KNOW WHAT WE REFER
TO AS A HOUSEHOLD MISFORTUNE SO
THIS IS SOMETHING SUCH AS A
NATURAL DISASTER OR A
REFRIGERATOR BREAKING DOWN
UNEXPECTEDLY. SO WE DON'T HAVE
A CURRENTLY A PROPOSAL RELATED
TO REPLACING AS A BEER TMB
BENEFITS THAT SAID I WANT TO
PROVIDE SOME BACKGROUND ON THE
ISSUE AND HIGHLIGHT
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS SUCH A PROPOSAL
WERE UNDER CONSIDERATION. FOR
REGULAR CAL FRESH AT THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL- THE BENEFIT
REPLACEMENT AMOUNT WHEN THERE
IS A HOUSEHOLD MISFORTUNE IS
DEPENDENT ON THE AMOUNT OF
FOOD- THAT WAS REPORTED AS LOST
WHETHER THAT FOOD WAS A
PERISHABLE OR NON PERISHABLE-
AND WHAT TYPE OF HOUSEHOLD
MISFORTUNE IT WAS SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOUR FRIDGE BREAKS
WE'RE GOING TO REPLACE
PERISHABLE FOODS IF YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED A FLOOD WE'RE GOING
TO REPLACE ALL OF THE FOOD
PURCHASED IT ALSO DEPENDS ON
THE TIME OF THE MONTH. BECAUSE
WE MAKE SOME ASSUMPTIONS AROUND
HOW MUCH FOOD WOULD BE LEFT
AVAILABLE TO YOU- AT THE
BEGINNING. OF THE MONTH VERSES
AT THE END OF THE MONTH. WE ALL
WORK BENEFITS CALFRESH BOTTOM.
SO THIS AMOUNT IS BASED ON THE
TYPE OF DISASTER AND THE TYPE
OF- THAT WAS LOST IN THE TIME
OF THE MONTH SO VERY SIMILAR.
WE REPLACE BENEFITS ON AN
AUTOMATIC BASIS. USING A
PERCENTAGE FORMULA SO IF UP A
MAJORITY OF HOUSEHOLDS IN AN
AREA ACCOUNT TO YEARS OF CODE
EXPERIENCE HOUSEHOLD MISFORTUNE
THAT LED TO ASSUME FOOD LOSS
SUCH AS AN EXTENDED POWER
OUTAGE. THEN WE'RE ABLE TO
AUTOMATICALLY REPLACE FOOD AT A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE. 100% OF
YOUR BENEFIT TOTAL. SO WHEN WE
ARE REPLACING BENEFITS AT THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL WE MUST
RECEIVE AT THE COUNTY A REQUEST
FOR REPLACEMENT USUALLY
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE TEN DAYS TO DO
THAT WE OFTEN EXTENDED TO
THIRTY DAYS- WE THEN ISSUE THE
REPLACEMENT AMOUNT BASED ON
THAT DETERMINATION. AND WE MUST
BE ABLE TO REPORT THESE
BENEFITS SEPARATELY FROM
REGULAR CALFRESH. WHEN WE
REPLACE BENEFITS
PROBLEMATICALLY WE DO THAT BY
WORKING WITH OUR SAWS
ELIGIBILITY SYSTEM AGAIN WE
USUALLY USE A PERCENTAGE BASED
FORMULA AND THEY RUN A PROCESS
OVERNIGHT AND YOU SHOULD THE
REPLACEMENTS ALL AT ONCE. THE
REPLACEMENT IS USUALLY
SCHEDULED AGAINST OTHER CHANGES
OR- CROSS THE SEAS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN OUR ELIGIBILITY
SYSTEM SO WE SCHEDULE IT BASED
ON THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
SYSTEM AND JUST LIKE WHEN WE
REPLACE THEM INDIVIDUALLY WE
MUST BE ABLE TO TRACK THEM
SEPARATELY THEN REGULAR CAL
FRESH. BENEFITS THE- YOU CAN
SEE THAT THERE IS BOTH MANUAL
WORK AND AUTOMATED WORK
INVOLVED WITH ISSUING
REPLACEMENTS DEPENDING ON HOW
THAT HAPPENS SO IT WOULD
REQUIRE FOR THIS TO HAPPEN IN
THE S. N. B. N. T. N. B.
PROGRAMS FOR OUR SYSTEM
AUTOMATION TO BE UPDATED AS
WELL SO THAT WE CAN ISSUE THOSE
REPLACEMENT BENEFITS AND KEEP
THEM SEPARATE AND APART FROM
YOUR REGULAR S. N. B. OR T. M.
B. BENEFITS. RIPARIAN
OPERATIONAL SIMPLICITY. I WOULD
ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE
REPLACEMENT PROCESS NEARER THE
CALFRESH REPLACEMENT PROCESS. I
WAS SO THAT CLIENTS ARE. BETTER
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
REPLACEMENT IS BEING DETERMINED
AND SO THAT OUR ELIGIBILITY
WORK FORCE CAN ALSO- GET CAUGHT
UP TO SPEED AND NOT HAVE THOSE
DIFFERENCES IN PROGRAM RULES.
AND THE FEASIBILITY OF
AUTOMATING THE CHANGE WOULD OF
COURSE NEED TO BE CONSIDERED IN
CONTEXT OF OTHER AUTOMATION
PARTIES AND OUR MIGRATION TO
COUNSEL US. AND I'M READY TO
SPEAK TO THE ASSEMBLY TMB
KEESLER TRENDS BUT LET ME JUST
PAUSE AND SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS ON REPLACEMENT. I
GUESS JUSTIN EDUCATE ME HOW HOW
ARE PEOPLE INFORMED THAT
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
REPLACEMENTS. IF IT'S NOT
AUTOMATIC. SO UNFORTUNATELY IN
CALIFORNIA- OF THE EXPERIENCE
RESPONDING TO WILDFIRES AND
DISASTERS HAS ACTUALLY MADE-
COUNTY'S AGAIN CLIENTS QUITE
FAMILIAR WITH THE AVAILABILITY
SO. ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE'S
EXTENDED POWER OUTAGE OR
SOMETHING LIKE A WILDFIRE IN
THE AREA WE'RE COMMUTING KADING
THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE
REPLACEMENTS TO CLIENTS AND
AGAIN UNFORTUNATELY IF IT
SOMETHING THAT HAS OCCURRED
PREVIOUSLY IN THAT COMMUNITY
WHICH IS OTEN THE CASE OF
FAMILIES ARE QUITE FAMILIAR SO
WHEN THEY'RE- INDIVIDUALLY
AVAILABLE THAT'S THROUGHOUT OUR
REGION COMMUNICATIONS EFFORT.
WHEN THEY'RE ISSUED
AUTOMATICALLY WE TRY TO PAIR
THAT WITH CLIENT COMMUNICATION
SUCH AS OUTBOUND TEXT MESSAGES
UPDATES TO OUR PHONE SYSTEM
RECORDINGS SO THAT CLIENTS KNOW
WHY THOSE ADDITIONAL BENEFITS
HAVE BEEN LOADED ONTO THEIR
CARD. OKAY AND I AND I HAVE
CERTAINLY SEEN A LOT OF
ACTIVITY AROUND THEM WITH THE
WILDFIRES AND PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY MAY BE ABLE TO GET
FOOD REPLACE BUT WHAT ABOUT
LIKE. IT DIDN'T IN THE END AND
STOCKTON WE HAD OVER FIFTY
FIFTY HOURS OF POWER BEING OUT
FOR SOME FAMILIES. WHO YOU KNOW
ARE ARE YOU WE'RE NOT A WELFARE
RECIPIENT USED TODAY IT WAS
JUST A BIG. THE OLD TREES AND
ABOVE GROUND WIRES. SO THAT
WOULD QUALIFY AND I'M GONNA GET
A LITTLE INTO THE WEEDS IF
YOU'LL BEAR WITH ME IF THE
OUTAGE LASTED FOR MORE THAN
FOUR HOURS AND IT IMPACTED MORE
THAN 50% OF HOUSEHOLDS IN AN
AREA SUCH AS THE ZIP CODE OR
COUNTY AND SO THE PROCESS OF
FOR THAT WE MONITOR. THESE
EVENTS CAREFULLY AND WHEN WE
SEE THAT THERE MAY BE A
QUALIFYING EVENT ME REACH OUT
TO THE CORRESPONDING UTILITY
COMPANIES AND WE HAVE TO SUBMIT
TO YOU. DATA THATPROVES THAT
FOOD LOSS CAN BE ASSUMED AS A
RESULT OF THE EVENT USDA THEN
HAS TO APPROVE THAT REQUEST IN
DETERMINE TO WHAT PERCENTAGE WE
WILL REPLACE THE FOOD SO WE
HAVE WORKING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
UTILITY PROVIDERS SUCH AS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
PG&E- WE'RE WE'RE REGULARLY
ABLE TO PULL DATA- AS A RESULT
OF. AN EVENT LIKE THAT. THANK
YOU. DISTURBANCE OKAY PLEASE
CONTINUE. OKAY SO LET ME-
LASTLY SPEAK TO TRENDS IN SMB
AND TMB CASELOAD SO BOTH- S. N.
B. N. T. N. B. CASELOADS PEAKED
AROUND DECEMBER NINETEEN
JANUARY TWENTY AND HAVE SINCE
DECLINED WITH HIM B.
PARTICIPATION DECLINING MORE
RAPIDLY BEGINNING AROUND THE
MAY TWENTY TWENTY MY SPEAK TO
WHY THAT THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THE DATA. THE SMB
CASELOADS TRUMP SMB CASELOAD
TRENDS WHERE CALFRESH
ELIGIBILITY SO HER S. N. B.
POLICY WE ARE ONLY ISSUING SMB
BENEFITS TO CALFRESH HOUSEHOLDS
WHO MAINTAIN THEIR CALFRESH
ELIGIBILITY AFTER IMPLEMENTING.
THE EXPANSION OF CALFRESH. SO
THAT CASE FOLLOWS WITH CALFRESH
TRENDS AND IT WOULD BE QUITE
CHALLENGING TO SEPARATE SMD
PARTICIPATION FROM CALFRESH
ENROLLMENT AS THAT WAS KIND OF
A CENTRAL COMPONENT OF OUR
IMPLEMENTATION. AB AND ALSO
HIGHLIGHT AS WE GET TO A COUPLE
OTHER QUESTIONS YOUR THEREIS
NO UNIQUE. RECERTIFICATION OR
BENEFIT MAINTENANCE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE SMB
PROGRAM AS LONG AS YOU MAINTAIN
CALFRESH ELIGIBILITY AND YOU
WORK AT AN SMB HOUSEHOLD YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE TO MAINTAIN SMB. THE
TMB OKAY SO IT IS QUITE
DIFFERENT IT STANDS ALONE AND
PER TMB POLICY- TìM BEAT
BENEFITS WERE ISSUED TO FORMER
CALFRESH HOUSEHOLDS WHO LOST
ELIGIBILITY AFTER IMPLEMENTING
THE EXPANSION. SO TMB HOUSEHOLD
WERE INITIALLY REQUIRED TO
RECERTIFY THEIR TMB AT TWELVE
MONTHS AFTER THAT KIND OF
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE POLICY
CHANGE AND SO WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING IN THE DATA IS THAT AS
WE HAD THAT TWELVE MONTH MARK
WE DID START TO SEE. A DECLINE
IN THE CASELOAD AND- THERE ARE
REQUIRED TO RECERTIFY EVERY SIX
MONTHS THEREAFTER SO THAT THAT
DECLINE HAS CONTINUED. THE TMB
RESEARCH AND JUST TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROCESS TO
UNDERSTAND- HOW THAT MIGHT
IMPACT BENEFIT MAINTENANCE IS A
TWO PAGE RECERTIFICATION FORM
AND SO TO MAINTAIN ELIGIBILITY
HOUSEHOLDS ARE REQUIRED SHOULD
CONFIRM WHETHER THERE HAVE BEEN
ANY CHANGES IN THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES. IF CHANGES ARE
REPORTED SO FOR EXAMPLE I THINK
RECENT INCOME FOR A CHANGE OF
THE ORIGINAL SSI RECIPIENTS WHO
MAY NOT BE PART OF THE
HOUSEHOLD THEY MUST APPLY FOR
CALFRESH THAT IS. PART OF OUR
TEAM BE POLICY. IF THEY'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH THEY CAN
STATE ON TMB- IF THEY CHANGED-
HAS- RESULTED IN THE ORIGINAL
SSI RECIPIENTS LEADING THEY
WILL- FINANCIALLY SEE KIND OF A
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH CHANGE THAT
THEY MAY OR MAY NOT BE ELIGIBLE
FOR CALFRESH. AND THEN- LASTLY
THERE ARE A GROUP OF PEOPLE
UNKNOWN AT THIS NUMBER WERE
CONDUCTING MORE ANALYSIS ON
THIS WHO MAY NOT HAVE COMPLETED
THE RECERTIFICATION- AT ALL
AND- THEY HAVE THIRTY DAYS TO
RETURN TO THE PROGRAM ONCE OR
BENEFITS FOR DISCONTINUED OR
THEY WILL HAVE A LOS TMB
ELIGIBILITY I PERMANENTLY. AND
NOT WITH THE RECERTIFICATION IS
TWO PAGES RECEPTORS YOU SAID
THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE ARE FALLING
OFF WHEN THEY HAVE TO BE
CERTIFIED. YES WE MADE IT AS-
SIMPLE AS WE COULD- WITH IN
KIND OF THE PARAMETERS THAT
WERE SET FOR US IN IN CODE AT
THE TIME WE IMPLEMENTED AND SO
IT IS IT TOO PAGE FORM WITH
ABOUT FOUR QUESTIONS. AND
THERE'S AND WE CAN MAIL THAT
AND THERE'S NO WAY TO DO THAT
BY PHONE AT THIS POINT. SO WE
DO ALLOW. IT TO BE SIGNED
ELECTRONICALLY SO IF A CLIENT
WERE TO CALL IN. THE COUNTY
WOULD HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SORT
OF FILL IT OUT AND SIGN IT ON
BEHALF OF THE CLIENT OVER THE
PHONE. BUT IT IS INITIALLY-
MAIL TO THE CLIENT AS WELL AS A
REMINDER. WE DIDN'T CLANKING
MAIL BACK IN WITH HER A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVING TO GO TO THE
COUNTY OFFICE. I'M FEELING VERY
UNSAFE DURING THIS TIME. RIGHT
NOW YES ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW WE
ARE PRIMARILY IN THIS IS FOR
CAL FRACTION- TMB SMB WE ARE
OPERATING OVER OF THE PHONE.
AND ONLINE AND SO WHILE THERE
ISN'T AN ONLINE VERSION OF THE
TEAM BEFORE IT CAN BE COMPLETED
OVER THE PHONE. THANK YOU OKAY.
OKAY. THANK YOU SHOULD MOVE ON.
OKAY SO I HAVE THE NEXT ISSUE
AS WELL- THIS IS RELATED TO
OUR- CALFRESH OPERATIONS
SUPPORT B. C. P. I SAW THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES THREE NEW
POSITIONS AND POSITION OF
AUTHORITY FOR NINETEEN EXISTING
POSITIONS. LET ME START WITH
THE NEW POSITIONS FIRST A NEW
INFORMATION- SERVICES POSITION
TO OVERSEE AND MAINTAIN OUR
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF IT USED TO
BE LIKE BEFORE I CAN STOP YOU
FROM IT I NEED TO GO BACK. TO
THE ISSUE FOR THE L. A. L.
PROJECT. HI JACQUELINE BRAZIL
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE
OUR OFFICE IS ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE
PROPOSED ADJUSTMENTS TO THE S.
N. B. T. N. B. BENEFIT AMOUNTS
AND ALSO LOOKING AT CURRENT
CASELOAD TRENDS TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING- EXIT RATES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT- AS IT
PERTAINS TO THE SECOND
QUESTION- INVOLVING THAT THE
FEASIBILITY OF. S. ISSUING
REPLACEMENT BENEFITS FOR US IN
BEING TEAM BE CASE SAYS- AS THE
DEPARTMENT NOTED THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS TO TAKE IN
CONSIDERATION I'M SUCH AS THE
NEEDED AUTOMATION CHANGES TO
JUST FLAG FOR THE LEGISLATURE-
THAT- IN LOOKING AT.
IMPLEMENTING SUCH A SYSTEM. IT
MAY BE HELPFUL TO GET
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON- IF
THAT AUTOMATION CHANGE WERE
PRIORITIZED WHICH HOW WOULD IT
IMPACT THE TIMELINESS OF
EXISTING SYSTEM CHANGES THAT
ARE IN FLIGHT BUT THEN ALSO HOW
WOULD IT IMPACT- IS SYSTEM
CHANGES THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
Q. AND TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF- HOW LONG IT
WOULD TAKE TO IMPLEMENT.
AUTOMATION CHANGE TO THEN BEGIN
ISSUING THOSE REPLACEMENT
BENEFITS TO S. N. B. N. TEAM BE
CASES. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
ANDERSON. OKAY SO- I WILL START
WITH THE NEW POSITIONS SO
INFORMATION SERVICES OR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY POSITION
TO OVERSEE AND MAINTAIN
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE NEW
TOOL ACCOUNT FRESH CONFIRM SO
THEY CALPERS CONFIRM TOOL WAS
BUILT TO VERIFY CALIBRATION
BRAWL MEANT ORIGINALLY FOR
PURPOSES OF PROVIDING CALFRESH
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
SERVICES- SO THIS IS A
REQUIREMENT OF OUR EMPLOYMENT-
AND WORKFORCE SERVICES PROGRAM
THAT YOU CONFIRM YOUR SERVING
SOMEONE WHO'S RECEIVING
CALFRESH. I'M AND IT'S REQUIRED
TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT BY OUR NETWORK OF
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE SO
THIS INCLUDES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- SUCH AS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- GOODWILL'S
AND SO ON SO ALL OF OUR
PROVIDERS NEED TO CONFIRM THAT
ENROLLMENT. THE LONG TERM
VISION AT THAT IS THAT THE TOOL
CAN ALSO BE USED TO VERIFY CAL
FRESHEN ROLE MEANT TO CONNECT
CALIFORNIANS TO OTHER ESSENTIAL
SERVICES SUCH AS REDUCED COURT
FINES- REDUCE COST PHONE AND
INTERNET SERVICES TRANSIT
PASSES I MEAN THE LIST CAN GO
ON AND ON AS CALFRESH SHOULD BE
THE INDICATOR OF ELIGIBILITY.
FOR THOSE OTHER SERVICES. SO
WELL THIS FOR INSURERS OUR
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO MEET THAT DEMAND
FOR WORK FOR SERVICES
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC RELATED DOWNTURN. AND
THAT THE WORLD MEDIATING COUNTY
AND LOCAL ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS THAT MAY PREVENT OUR
PARTNERS FROM PARTICIPATING. OF
COURSE INCREASING ACCESS TO
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES DURING THE
PANDEMIC- WOULD BE A GOAL AS
WELL. A SECOND NEW POSITION IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SEXTANT SECTION
CHIEF SO THEY ARE REQUESTED TO
LEAD OUR EXISTING CALFRESH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TEAM WHICH
HAS GROWN OVER TIME AND IS NOW
MADE UP OF SIX- MANAGERS THAT
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALIZED TA TO
THEIR ASSIGNED COUNTIES- THEY
WORK WITH- TEAM MANAGERS TO
IDENTIFY BOTH COUNTY SPECIFIC
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NEEDS. BUT
ALSO STATEWIDE NEEDS- AND THE
SECTION CHIEF IS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP
PROVIDE A PROMOTE MORE
STATEWIDE CONSISTENCY AND THAT
UNIFIED HIM STATEWIDE VISION
FOR INCREASING ACCESS
OPERATIONS AND POLICY. AND THIS
TEAM IS REALLY THAT- BRIDGE
BETWEEN POLICY AND OUR
OPERATIONS WORK AND SO THEY ARE
ON HOW IN THE FIELD MAKING SURE
THAT OUR POLICY IS IMPLEMENTED-
WITH FOCUS ON ACCESS AND VICE
VERSA THAT WE ARE INFORMED OF
THE RIGHT POLICIES. TO SUPPORT
THAT ACCESS. AND THE THIRD OF
THE FINAL NEW POSITION IS
ACCOUNT FOOD JUST. SECTION
CHIEFS OF THIS IS OVER OUR
EMERGENCY FOOD PROGRAMS TO LEAD
OUR EXISTING TEAMS BUT ALSO THE
NEWEST EDITION WHICH IS A UNIT
DEDICATED TO OUR STATE
EMERGENCY FOOD PROGRAMS WHICH
HAVE GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. OF
PROVIDING THE LEADERSHIP
NECESSARY TO BALANCE THAT
EXISTING WORKLOAD BUT TO
INCREASE COLLABORATION WITH OUR
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS AND
ADVISORY GROUP MEMBERS. IN
ADDITION- BETTER EQUIPPING US
TO MANAGE FUTURE STATE
INVESTMENTS IN THE EMERGENCY
PHONE SYSTEM THAT'S A QUITE A
CRITICAL MOMENT FOR US AS WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING A NEW SERVICE
DELIVERY MODEL IN THIS AREA- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THE CAPACITY TO MEET.
BOTH ARE FEDERAL PROGRAMS-
EXPECTATIONS AND THE STATE
FUNDING EXPECTATIONS. AND
LASTLY THE REQUEST EXPOSITION
AUTHORITY FOR NINETEEN EXISTING
POSITIONS WITHIN THE BRANCH SO
WE HIRE THESE POSITIONS TO MEET
IMMEDIATE NEED AND WE'RE NOW
GOING THROUGH THIS FORMAL
BUDGET PROCESS TO SEEK
AUTHORITY FOR THE POSITIONS. OF
MEDIA NEED INCLUDED SPECIAL
PROJECTS AND INITIATIVES
FOCUSED ON INCREASING ACCESS
AND PARTICIPATION SOME OF WHICH
I'VE ALREADY SPOKEN TO TODAY
BUT ALSO- MEETING FEDERAL
COMPLIANCE STANDARDS RELATED
TO. QUALITY CONTROL AND
MANAGEMENT EVALUATIONS THAT
HAVE RESULTED AS IT IN AS OUR
CASELOAD HAS INCREASED SO HAS
THE PROGRAM. IS GROWING WE ARE
EXPECTED TO MEET ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL ASKING UNDER ITS FOR
OVERSIGHT AND ALBION CALFRESH
THEY'RE ALSO POSITION
SUPPORTING OUR CALFRESH HEALTHY
LIVING. A PROGRAM WHICH IS OUR
NUTRITION EDUCATION- PROGRAM
HERE AT CDSS. ADEQUATE STAFFING
ALLOWS A BRANCH TO CONTINUE
MEETING PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY ENSURES
THAT AFFECTED ADMINISTRATION OF
THE PROGRAM WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
ACCESS AND BENEFIT RETENTION
STREAMLINED OPERATIONS AND-
SERVING CALIFORNIA'S HARDEST.
TO SERVE OUR POPULATIONS
EQUITABLY. HOW WILL WE KNOW IF
YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL. WELL I WOULD
THERE ARE A COUPLE INDICATORS
THAT WE TRACK CLOSELY OF COURSE
OUR PARTICIPATION RATE BEING-
CRITICAL- WE LOOK AT- BENEFIT
RETENTION SO AS IT RELATES TO
OUR CHURN RATES AND THEN UP IN
THE WEEDS WE ALSO LOOK AT OUR
ACCURACY AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO BOTH US AS ADMINISTRATORS
BUT TO CLIENTS MAKING SURE THAT
WERE INSURING BENEFITS.
ACCURATELY AND THAT WE ARE A
MEETING- PROGRAM EXPECTATIONS
AROUND ACCESS- ON THE GROUND-
AND AVOIDING THINGS LIKE- OVER
PAYMENTS AND WHATNOT WHICH WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE FOR ANY OF
OUR CLIENTS SO A FUTURE DATE
INDICATORS THAT WE TRACK QUITE
CLOSELY. WE LIKE TO SEE THOSE
ALL IMPROVE MMHM. THANK YOU CAN.
CAN I JUST WAS SO WHY I MEAN IF
IT. WHAT DO WE THINK THAT WE
HAVE SOME OF THE LOWEST RATES
OF SOME PEOPLE FINING UP ON
CALFRESH AND I GUESS HOW CLOSE
DO WE WORK WITH THE FOOD BANKS
TO BE ABLE TO CATCH THE
POPULATION WHO WHO WERE THERE
AND PERHAPS NOT A CALFRESH.
YEAH SO LET ME SPEAK UP. TO THE
SECOND PART OF YOUR QUESTION
FIRST AND THEN I'LL GET TO IT
NUMBER PARTICIPATION RATE BUT-
THAT THE- BANKS ARE PART OF
OUR- FORMAL OUTREACH NETWORK SO
WE DO HAVE. A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS
TO ENSURE THAT FOOD BANKS AND
OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. ARE ON THE
GROUND PROVIDING APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE IN GETTING THE WORD
OUT SO THEY ARE- DEEPLY ENGAGE
AND CAL FRESH OUTRAGE WORK AND-
OFTEN SOME OF OUR STRONGEST
ADVOCATES FOR INCREASED
PARTICIPATION. THEY SEE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS A MUCH MORE
SUSTAINABLE- RESOURCE FOR
FAMILIES AND THEN THE EMERGENCY
FOOD NETWORK SO THEY ARE DEEPLY
ENGAGED. IN INCREASING
PARTICIPATION. OF THE QUESTION
AROUND WHY ARE PARTICIPATION
RATE IS- NOT HIGHER THE SORT OF.
BEEN LONG STANDING KIND OF
CONTENT AND DEPENDING ON WHO
YOU'RE TALKING TO THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF REASONS FROM. THAT
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE'S
POPULATION TO- V. IMMIGRANT
POPULATION TO KIND OF- LONG AGO
WE SORT OF CAUGHT UP A POLICY
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE AROUND
A FEDERAL OPTIONS SUCH AS
REPORTING RIGHT AND SO THAT
THEY GAP AROUND POLICY
DECISIONS WE'VE WE'VE CLOSED AS
BEST AS POSSIBLE AND SO WE DO
THINK THERE REMAINS SORT OF A-
GETTING THE WORD OUT- REDUCING
STIGMA AND MAKING SURE THAT
POPULATIONS WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
UNSURE ABOUT HOW FRESH ARE UP
TO SPEED ON. ITS AVAILABILITY
AND IMPACTS ON THEIR OWN A
STATUS IF THAT'S APPLICABLES.
OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY GOT
ILLEGAL ANYTHING. THE THING.
OKAY. MOVING ON. NEXT WE HAVE
CORRENTI CANNON SPEAKING TO THE
HOUSING ISSUES. GOOD AFTERNOON.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON HI FOLKS MY
NAME IS CARLENE YOU CANON AND I
SERVE AS THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
OF HOUSING HOMELESSNESS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. SO TO BEGIN TODAY I
WANTED TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD ROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD
THE COUNTY'S ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION OF ADULT AND
SENIOR CARE. FACILITIES
INCLUDING AT WORK HOLD ARCS
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AS
WELL AS GARCIA BEATS WHICH ARE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES.
ELDERLY AND LASTLY FOR RC ACT.
I RC F. B. I.'S WHICH ARE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE CHRONIC. SO THIS PROPOSAL
BE EMPLOYED IN A LINE WITH THE
PROPOSAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL- THAT
PROPOSAL WOULD EXPAND TREATMENT
IN RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS. WITH
YOU BROUGHT HEALTH. SO IN THE
ADULT AND SENIOR CARE FACILITY
SIDE WHICH IS THE TERM THAT WE
USE TO DESCRIBE OUR- I THANK.
I'M PROVIDE A STRUCTURED HOME
LIKE ENVIRONMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT OTHERWISE REQUIRE
INSTITUTIONAL. SO ARTS RCS FEES
ARE PART OF A CONTINUUM OF LONG
TERM CARE SUPPORT PROVIDING NON
MEDICAL CARE AND SUPERVISION TO
ADULTS WHO MAY HAVE MENTAL
PHYSICAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THOSE WHO ARE
AGE SIXTY AND OVER WHO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL WORK. BUT MANY OF
THE RESIDENTS IN THE SETTINGS
ARE AGE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER
PEOPLE WHO ARE BLIND OR HAVE TO
BELIEVE IN ME MAY RECEIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME
AND STATE. I I'M SO IMPORTANT
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA HAS A
SHORTAGE I ADULT LOSING YOUR
CHARACTERS THAT ACCEPT SS I SS
YOUR RECIPIENT AND HAS
EXPERIENCED A DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF SS I SS THE
RECIPIENTS THAT RESIDE IN ADULT.
FROM WORK OR TWENTY NIGHT. BUT
THE THIRD. OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
LAST WORK WHICH WE HAVE THE ACT
THERE'S BEEN A DECREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY SIX PERCENT. IN
THE NUMBER OF SS I SS THE
RECIPIENTS RESIDING IN ADULTS.
THE FOR PROFIT. THEREFORE THE
GOAL OF THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM IS TO CREATE
A NEW ADULT AND SENIOR KERR-
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN PARTICULAR I'M
WITH THE FOCUS ON SENIORS AND
THOSE WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
AS WELL AS STABILIZER EXISTING
SETTINGS BUT FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS OR
UNNECESSARY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION PATTERSON
DON'T. YES FUNDS WOULD BE
PRIORITIZED THE CREATION OF NEW
AND EXPANDED SETTINGS BUT COULD
ALSO BE USED TO FUND CAPITAL
INVESTMENT AND REHABILITATION
COSTS FOR EXISTING SETTINGS
THAT ARE AT RISK OF. WHEN
APPLYING FOR THESE BONDS THE
COUNTIES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
DEMONSTRATE COMMITMENT
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO ENSURE
THE STABILITY OF ANYONE WHO'S
BASED. IN LEEDS ADULT YOUR-
BODY. THIS PROPOSAL WEBER LOCAL
INVESTMENT AND HE'S- INCLUDES
OUT HOW THE FUNDING OR OTHER
FUNDING THAT GO THAT ROUTE THE
LADY FOR AUXILIARY FOR. OR IN
MANY COULD BE THROUGH THE OF
SERVICES ADDITION SERVICES ON I
THINK OF WORK ON THEIR OP. I'LL
ALSO NOTE THAT WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SO. THAT
THEY A ROAD MAP FOR THE
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
CONTINUE ON WHICH INCLUDES
ADULT AND SENIOR TECHNOLOGY.
WHAT DO YOU THAT WOULD RISK AN-
FUNDING MADE PURCHASED AND
OWNED BY COUNTY. OR COULD BE
OPERATOR. AN EXISTING
FACILITIES THAT RECEIVE THIS WE
HAVE FUNDING COULD CONTINUE TO
BE OWNED BY AN EXISTING OWNER
OPERATOR. IMPORTANT THESE
FACILITIES WOULD MAINTAIN
COVENANTS OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
USE RESTRICTIONS TO CERTIFY
THEIR INTENDEDUSE AND A
RESIDENT POPULATION. YES IS
UNIQUELY SITUATED TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM THE ENTITY
RESPONSIBLE FOR LICENSING AND
MONITORING IN YOUR CARE
FACILITIES. AS WELL AS PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE MANY OF THE SAME.
SERVICES IN THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM.
YES I ALSO BE ADMINISTRATOR I
WOULD BE AT HOUSING DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
HOUSING AND DISABILITY
ADVOCATES FOR THE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. I FOR SSI SS AND
THE SAFETY PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES HOUSING AND HOUSING
RELATED SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
WERE SERVED VITAL. I'M THAT
NUMBER OKAY BUT- THAT COULD
BENEFIT FROM THESE FUNDS WILL
DEPEND ON THE PROPORTION OF
FUNDING THAT WILL BE USED FOR
EXPANSION VERSUS PRESERVATION.
AND THIS PROPORTION WILL BE
BASED ON THE LOCAL GAS AND
NEEDS ASSESSMENT- WILL BE A
PART OF. IT OKAY OF FACILITIES-
ACQUISITION AND WE HAVE WOULD
BE MORE COSTLY THAN FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE A LONG I'M SOME
COMMUNITIES DON'T MAKE FOCUS ON
EXPANSION IF THERE ARE YOU OR
NOFACILITIES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
I OTHER COMMUNITIES MAY FOCUS
ON PRESERVING THE FACILITIES
THAT ALREADY EXIST. THREE WE
HAVE FUNDING. AND THEREFORE
PRESERVING FACILITIES AND- BY
DOING SO IT ALSO INCENTIVIZING
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO THE
TARGET POPULATION THROUGH THESE
BEHALF ON. THE SENSE OF THE
LANDSCAPE IN CALIFORNIA I'LL
SHARE SOME DATA ON THESE
FACILITY. IN THE THIRD QUARTER
OF TWENTY TWENTY. NUMBER THERE
WERE TWO THOUSAND AND FORTY
SEVEN ADULT AND SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES LICENSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES WE OF COURSE OF BAGS
THAT STIR INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING
SS I SS HE- SAID THIS DOES
EXCLUDE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SPENDING. IS BETTER- RENDERED
EAT REGIONAL CENTERS FOR PEOPLE
WITHOUT IT. I'M BEING USED I
TWO THOUSAND AND FORTY SEVEN
FACILITIES THEY HAVE A CAPACITY
OF OVER 600-006-1000. ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO BAD. BUT
I'M OF THE FACILITIES I JUST
JUST. NOT ALL ARE RECEIVING SSI
B. AT ANY GIVEN TIME OKAY AWAY
FROM OUR MOST RECENT DATA AGAIN
FROM THAT THE THIRD QUARTER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THERE ARE UP TO
AN ESTIMATED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND THREE SS I
RECIPIENTS LIVING ADULT AND-
CALIFORNIA. I'M TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE BREAKDOWN BETWEEN
ADULT AND SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES THERE ARE 52% OF
THOSE. FIFTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS ROUGHLY WHO ARE
LIVING IN ADULT CARE SETTINGS
AND 48% WHO ARE RESIDING. IN
YOUR CARE ACT. THE MOST
IMPORTANT FIGURE IN FOR THIS.
WHICH I SHARED EARLIER IS THAT
FROM THE FOURTH QUARTER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN OF THE THIRD
QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
HAVE SEEN A DECREASE AND
APPROXIMATELY 6% THE NUMBER.
YOU WERE LIVING IN THE- BACK.
OF THIS PROPOSAL IS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THIS DECLINE AND
EXPANDING AND PRESERVING THE
LADIES A THIRD FFI AFTER THE
RECIPIENT. TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS. OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION. WITH HIGHER LEVEL
OF CARE HE- REALLY SEEMS. IF I
CAN ASK YEAH HAVE WE- THANK
HAVE WE HOW MANY BEDS ARE STILL
AVAILABLE. SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
FIFTY ONE HUNDRED. THAT WE HAVE
THAT WE HAVE. AND WE'VE SEEN A
DECLINE IN THE AMOUNT OF
EXERCISE PEOPLE IN THOSE BEDS.
HAVE WE SEEN A DECLINE IN THE
AMOUNT OF BEDS OR JUST THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
ESSENCE I S. S. P. IN THOSE
BETS. QUESTION SO WE DON'T HAVE
OCCUPANCY DATA FOR THESE
FACILITIES. BUT WE CAN TRACK
THE NUMBER SS I RECIPIENTS MOST
FACILITIES BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THE CENSUS IS GOING
DOWN AND- IT JUST MEANS THAT
THE NUMBER SS IRIS. CORRECT SO
I THE WOULD NOT LEAD US TO
BELIEVE THAT AND ONE OF THE
COMPLAINT I'VE HEARD. SINCE I
WAS AT A DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDER WAS THE LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR SS
SINUSES P. FOR RESIDENTIAL CARE.
SO IT DOES INCREASING MORE BEDS
ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF. BUT
PEOPLENOT BEING ABLE TO STAY
IN FACILITIES BECAUSE THE
FACILITIES CAN'T MAKE IT ON THE
RATE OF INCREASE IN PERSON.
YEAH SO THE INTENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO INCENTIVIZE.
THESE OPERATORS TO ACCEPT SSI
PARTICIPANTS AS A SITE
RECIPIENTS- INTO THEIR SETTINGS
I'M DOING SO BOTH THROUGH
ACQUISITION AND WE HAD FUNDING
BUT ALSO THROUGH LEVERAGING.
INVESTMENTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BUT I GOT THROUGH COUNTY
GOVERNMENT- ANISH CARE CLANS
AND OTHERS WHO CAN PROVIDE OF
THOSE AUXILIARY SERVICES IN
SETTINGS- WHICH AND IN SOME
CASES IT'S VERY DIRECT FUNDING
TO THE FACILITIES. AND IN SOME
CASES IT'S A PROVISION OF. IN
KIND SERVICES OR CALL LOCATING-
OTHER STAFF ON SITE TO. WORK
THE UNIQUE. NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION. AND WE THINK
HUNDRED MILLION IS GOING TO DO
IT FOR THIS OF CALIFORNIA. HOW
MANY WITH THAT KNOW. HOW DO WE
COME UP WITH THAT NUMBER. SO
AGAIN IT WILL BE IT IS A LITTLE
HARD TO PREDICT AT THIS POINT
THE EXACT NUMBER OF FACILITIES
THAT WE CAN START WITH FEES
FINES AND BECAUSE OF COURSE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH CREATING
NEW FACILITIES WHICH IS IN MANY
WAYS WILL WORK. ON AND TRY TO
DO HERE IS CREATE NET NEW
RESOURCES- BECAUSE THEY'RE SO
VALUABLE UT AGAIN ALSO HAVING
THE FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW US TO
PRESERVE SPENDING. ON THAT
COULD IT OPERATORS THAT COULD
EXIT THE MARKET. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE. NOT FOR EXAMPLE AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE AND IF THAT
ISN'T BACK THE RATE LIMITING
FACTOR ABOUT WHAT'S HOLDING
SOMEONE BACK WE CAN SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM. AS WELL. I THINK WE'LL
CONTINUE HAVE QUESTIONS ON THIS
ONE AND WE AT WE ALL JUST
RECEIVED BIG INTO OF CARE
PACKAGE AND THIS IS INCLUDED IN
THERE BUT WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO REVIEW IT YET. BUT
PLENTY OF QUESTIONS FOR WE GO
TO THE L. A. L. UGH ILIO
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THE SHORT
WILL START IF YOU HAND UP THERE
YES GOOD AFTERNOON ANGELES
SHORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- BEFORE DIVING
INTO MY COMMENTS- SPECIFICALLY
ON THE PROPOSAL FOR ADULT AND
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES I JUST
WANTED TO TAKE. A STEP BACK TO
BROADLY NOTE THAT THIS IS ONE
OF A FEW NEW KEY HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- ALL OF WHICH
ARE FOCUSED ON THE ACQUISITION
OR REHABILITATION OF PROPERTIES
OF SOME SORT USING ONE TIME
RESOURCES. AND WHAT WE
RECOGNIZE CERTAINLY
HOMELESSNESS IS A MAJOR
CHALLENGE FACING THE STATE WE
HAVE SOME- QUESTIONS IN GENERAL
ABOUT HOW THESE- PROPOSED
PROGRAMS WOULD TARGET
HOMELESSNESS ULTIMATELY WHAT
IMPACT THEY COULD HAVE
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE ONE
TIME IN NATURE OF THE FUNDS AND
ALSO HOW THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
WOULD COMPLEMENT ONE ANOTHER
GIVEN SOME OF THEIR OVERLAPPING
GOALS. ABOUT MOVING ON SPECIFIC
TO THE PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
ADULT AND SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS RELATED TO DATA
LIMITATIONS- THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IS ABLE TO
TRACK THE TOTAL NUMBER CAPACITY
AND LOCATIONS OF ARSON RCMP IS
THAT CLOSE. AS WELL AS NEW
FACILITIES THAT OPEN. HOWEVER
TO THE BEST OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING THERE IS NOT AG
AGGREGATED DATA AVAILABLE ABOUT
FIRST WHY FACILITIES ARE
CLOSING. FOR EXAMPLE DUE TO
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES- SECOND IF
THERE ARE CERTAIN TRAITS THAT
ARE COMMON TO THE FACILITIES
THAT ARE CLOSING FOR EXAMPLE
HAVING- MORE AS AS AS AS P.
RESIDENTS OR OR BELOW AVERAGE
MARKET. RATES AND THIRD WHAT
HAPPENS TO RESIDENTS ONE
FACILITIES CLOSE FOR EXAMPLE
WHETHER THEY BECOME HOMELESS OR
ARE ABLE TO MOVE INTO A
DIFFERENT FACILITY. AND WITHOUT
KNOWING THESE DATA POINTS
ASSESSING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT THESE
FACILITIES IS A BIT CHALLENGING.
IN PARTICULAR- GIVEN THESE
DELIMITATIONS WE REALLY DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS DRIVING ARE VAN
RCMP CLOSURES AND ACCORDINGLY
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW IF THE
PROPOSED ONE TIME FUNDS- WILL
BE AN EFFECTIVE TOOL TO ADDRESS
CLOSURES. FOR EXAMPLE- IF WE
KNEW THAT FACILITIES FOR
CLOSING DUE TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ISSUES THAT WOULD
HELP US UNDERSTAND IF ONE TIME-
IF A ONE TIME FUNDING APPROACH
WOULD BE- SUFFICIENT AT
MITIGATING CLOSURES WHILE
ALTERNATIVELY- AND DISCUSS TO
THE POINT THAT THE TERMINATE
REGARDING SS I SS P. RATES. IF
WE HAD DATA DEMONSTRATING THAT
CLOSURES ARE ACTUALLY DRIVEN
BY- THESE INSUFFICIENT RATES
THAT WE COULD ASSESS WHETHER A
MORE EFFECTIVE INTERVENTION TO
PREVENT CLOSURES MIGHT ACTUALLY
BE- TO INCREASE THOSE RATES FOR
ALL OF THE SS I SS P. NON
MEDICAL OUT OF HOME CARE. I ALL
OF ARE SAID. BUT AGAIN WITHOUT
THIS KNOWLEDGE IT'S JUST
CHALLENGING TO ASSESS- WHICH-
INTERVENTION MIGHT BE MORE
EFFECTIVE. AND THEN BEYOND DATA
LIMITATIONS- WE ALSO JUST
WANTED TO RAISE A FEW CONCERNS
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER-
AROUND THE LACK OF IMPLEMENTING
LEGISLATION FOR THIS PURPOSE
PROGRAM. SPECIFICALLY WE NOTE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
INDICATED- THERE WILL NOT BE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ESTABLISH THIS PROGRAM- BUT
RATHER THE PROGRAM WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED THROUGH BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE- WE DO NOTE THAT
DETAILS ARE STILL EVOLVING AND
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND- THE ADDITIONAL
DETAILS THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED
RECENTLY- BUT AT THIS POINT.
AND GIVEN THAT THERE WON'T BE
TRAILER ILL LANGUAGE WE JUST
HAVE A NUMBER OF MORE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS- ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROPOSAL
AND ALSO ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY OVERSEE THE
PROGRAM- FOR EXAMPLE AT THIS
POINT IT'S NOT CLEAR TO US HOW
THE FUNDS. WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
WE UNDERSTAND THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WOULD
ADMINISTER GRANTS AND THERE
WILL BE SOME SORT OF
APPLICATION PROCESS. WE'RE JUST
NOT COMPLETELY CLEAR ON HOW
FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOCATED AND
DISBURSED- ALSO. AGAIN STILL
WORKING UNDERSTAND ALL THE
DETAILS BUT WE'RE NOT CLEAR HOW
EXACTLY FACILITIES RECEIVING
FUNDS COULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
THEY BE REQUIRED TO SERVE- A
CERTAIN PROPORTION OF ISIS ISIS
P. RESIDENTS BUT THEY BE
REQUIRED TO REMAIN OPEN FOR A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME AS A
CONDITION OF RECEIVING FUNDS.
AT THIS POINT WHERE JUST NOT
CLEAR- SO JUST AND BY NOTING WE
RECENTLY PUBLISHED OUR ANALYSIS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S FULL HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS- PACKAGE OF
PROPOSALS. INCLUDING THIS
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT ARSON RCMP
IS- WHICH CAN BE FOUND ON OUR.
WEBSITE SO I'LL STOP THERE AND
HAPPY TO TRY TO ANSWER ANY LIKE.
OKAY IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE-
YOU'RE THINKING LIKE I WAS
THINKING. ALL RIGHT FROM SO DR
PAN- HAS LEFT. ANYTHING ON THE
PART OF FINANCE. WELL YES BRENT
HAUSER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AGAIN WOULD ONLY NO JUST IN
RELATION TO PROVIDING SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAIL AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THE FACT SHE WAS
RECENTLY SHARED THAT I THINK
WILL PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAIL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
TOPIC AS WELL AS-
ADMINISTRATION DOES PLAN ON
INCLUDING BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO OUTLINE SOME OF THE
STRUCTURAL COMPONENTS OF THE
PROGRAM AND ALSO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING. WITH THE
LEGISLATION THE COMING MONTHS
ON THAT LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY.
STILL BE INTERESTED THE TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT THIS AS AS WE GO
FORWARD. OKAY. SOME MOVING ON
THEN. OKAY GREAT CAREER THIS IS
CORINNE YOU CAN AGAIN HELLO- I
RAN AGAIN. YES HI YOU CAN AGAIN
I'M HAVING. SHARE OUR NEXT THE
NEXT ITEM- SO YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW THIS ONE IS
RELATED TO STAFFING REQUEST. SO
THIS PROPOSAL IS TO FIND THREE
POINT FIVE DSS YEAH REFER TO
EXISTING HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS THAT
SERVED. CAL WORKS FAMILIES. THE
FIRST IS THE- ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WE'RE REQUESTING ONE
POINT FIVE STAFF WHICH INCLUDES
ONE- ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM ANALYSTS AND ONE HALF
TIME STAFF SERVICES MANAGER ONE
BUT TO BE RESPONSIBLE TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE ONGOING COUNTY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AND
OVERSIGHT AS WELL AS
IMPLEMENTING THE MULTIPLE
POLICY CHANGES. SB AND SIXTY
FIVE. AND ALSO- BUT THE HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM BECAUSE HE AYE
THE PROPOSAL IS PRETTY STAFF
INCLUDING ONE STAFFORD MANAGER
WINE AND WINE IT GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM ANALYST
FOR THE CALIBER HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
STAFFING SUPPORT BASED ON
PROGRAM GROW OVER PREVIOUS
YEARS. IT. DID NOT INCLUDE I.
I'D LIKE TO JUST BRIEFLY SHARE
ON THE APPROACH THAT WE TAKE IN
OUR WORK TO AND- TO OUR TEAM
INTO. WITH LOCAL OPERATORS TO
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
EVIDENCE BASED AND REACH THE
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. I'M IN THAT FISCAL
YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY CSS I
SUPPORTED COUNTIES AND TRIBES
PROVIDING CRITICAL HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. OR HOUSING
INSTABILITY ACROSS OUR STICKS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAM. HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS TEAM WORKS WITH
OVER TWO HUNDRED LOCAL
PROGRAMS. TO PROVIDE INTENSIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
OVERSIGHT TO DELIVER THESE
WORK. THE WORK REQUIRE
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS STAFFED.
BY PROGRAM AND REQUIRES PROGRAM
WE UNDERSTAND THE SPECIFIC
LANDSCAPE. AND THE NEEDS OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. SHOP
ADDITIONAL THREE POINT FIVE
POSITION. POSITIONS WERE AND
PROPOSED WERE GROUP'S OF PRO
OUT. COOPER INNOVATION AND DATA
DRIVEN. ALSO JUST A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE- HOME REQUEST
FOR ONE THREE BY STAFF.
ABSOLUTELY THE COLOR HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WAS TO HELP
FAMILY IN MACAU PROGRAM YOU
COST SHARING HER PERMANENT. OR
TO PROVIDE AND SHELTER WHEN AT
THE END. WHAT VEHICLE YOU'RE
NINETY TWENTY. 650-005-0070
FOUR. WORKS FOR IN THE- PROGRAM.
ONE POINT FIVE POSITION IN THE
OF SYSTEMS WORK WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE- OF TENDS TO FIVE WHICH
MADE TO BE COULD CHANGE TO THE
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM INCLUDING
RECALL THAT TEMPORARY HOUSES.
GRANTORS AND ON THE DAY THAT
THE ON APPLY FOR HOMELESS AND
WE'RE THE ELEMENT REQUIREMENTS
FOR. HAVE THAN A HIGH DOLLARS
ACTUALLY YEAH THESE CHANGES I
WILL NOTE OUR EXPECT IN THE OF.
THE STAFF WORK ESPECIALLY WITH
THE SB TENDS FIVE CHANGES
PARTICULARLY AFTER AND YOU
GUIDANCE REGARDING THE POLICY
CHANGES IMPLEMENTED LEGISLATIVE
UPDATE YEAH COUNTY OUT REVISING
THE SPEED AND NOTICED THAT WAS
BROWN A STATE RIGHT. AND WORK
WITH THE SYSTEMS FOR THE TIMELY
ACT AUTOMATION THE PARTICULAR
HE. ON THE SIDE THAT HOUSE
SUPPORT PROGRAMS ON THE WORK
FOR TO STAFF THEIR- ALL JUST A
COUPLE OF A COUPLE OF. AND
THANK HOW WORKED SUPPORT
PROGRAM WAS BY SENATE BILL
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE INTO FOURTEEN
IS AN IN TO FOSTER HOUSE
STABILITY FOR EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OUR PROGRAM. IT IS
A STATE FUNDED RAPID RE HOUSING
PROGRAM BEST LOOK WITH MINISTER
I COUNTY DEPARTMENT. BERMAN
SAYS THE PROGRAM PROVIDES
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND OTHER
SUPPORT NEEDED TO REFER YEAH
I'M GOING TO MAKE OUR PROGRAM
WE'RE EXPERIENCING HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS YOU ACCESS AND
THEN RETAINS. ABLE HOUSING.
THEY JUST BE PROGRAM A COME
GRANT PROGRAM AND SPEECH
ALLOCATE FUNDS ARE CURRENTLY TO
FIFTY FOUR COUNTIES ACROSS
ACROSS THE STATE. THIS FOLLOWS
A CONTINUED TREND OF PROGRAMS
BROWN. GRAHAM STARTED INITIALLY
WITH TWENTY PARTICIPATING
COUNTIES IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
WE HAD ADDITIONAL COUNTIES WHO
OPTED IN EVERY YEAR SINCE WE'VE
WATCHED THE PROGRAM. THE STAFF
RESOURCES WERE PROVIDED TO DSS
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN THE
PROGRAM WAS FUNDED AT THIRTY
FIVE MILLION. EIGHT OUT AND
HAVE 35% SINCE THEN THE PROGRAM
HAS INCREASED TO NINETY FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY AND HAS
NINETEEN YOU COUNTY FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT THAT- BUT WITH NO
NEW STAFFING TO GO ALONG WITH.
CORRESPONDING INCREASES IN BOTH
FUNDING AND COUNTY YEAH. THE
NEW POSITIONS THAT WERE
REQUESTING WOULD SUPPORT
PROGRAM EXPANSION BUT HAPPENED
IN THESE PREVIOUS YEARS AS WELL
AS THE ON GOING POLICY AND
PROGRAM GUIDE AND EAT. CRITICAL
TO SUPPORT THE STRONGEST
PROGRAM POSSIBLE TO COMBAT
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS. INTENSIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDED
BY OUR TEAM AND WE BELIEVE IS
ESPECIALLY CRITICAL GIVEN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES FACED BY FAMILIES
AND PROPERTY INTO WORKS. FOR
OUR PROGRAM. IT WAS A QUESTIONS.
ABOUT HOW THE- AS A SUPPORT
PROGRAM IN IRAQ WITH OTHER
PROGRAMS IN DSS OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO TARGET
ASSISTANCE TO HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS SO I'M I WILL SAY
THAT AGAIN THESE THESE TWO
PROGRAMS HOMELESS THE HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND HST
PROGRAM ARE BOTH ABOUT MEETING
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF HOMEWORK
HOUSEWORK YEAH. YES THAT'S AS
MADE A CONCERTED EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT ESPECIALLY THE- I'M
HOUSING. PROGRAM IS KIND. WITH
LOCAL HOMELESS CONTINUUM HAIR
AND COORDINATED ENTRY. WHICH
ALLOWS OUR OPERATORS ACCESS
HOUSING SERVICES IN THE BROADER
HOLD. IT ALSO CREATES PATHWAYS
FOR THOSE SAME AND HOUSING
PROVIDERS TO BETTER LEVERAGE
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO MEET.
THE NEEDS OF OUR- WITCH'S COURT
LONG TERM HOUSING ELEGY. IN
OTHER WORDS THESE PROGRAMS
SUPPORT EACH OTHER BY ENSURING
ACCESS TO SERVICES ALONG WHAT
WE WOULD CONSIDER I CONTINUE ON
MY HOUSING RESOURCES. MICHAEL
WE WOULD UTILIZE. THE TEMPORARY
EMERGENCY SHELTER AVAILABLE
RECALL THAT HA PROGRAM ****
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM PRIOR TO
HOUSING SOMEONE THREW IT BACK
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH
IS A LONGER TERM. AND THEN IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
HOUSING SUPPORT PARTICIPANTS-
WERE SEARCHED RAPID RE HOUSING
MODEL SOME OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
MAY ACTUALLY NEED A LONGER TERM
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. AND THAT'S
WHY THE CONNECTION TO THE
HOMEWORK YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR IS
SO IMPORTANT. I THANK ON
CONNECT PEOPLE WHO NEED IT. YOU
LONGER TERM DIRECTION- I'M JUST
ADVISING THAT THESE THREE POINT
FIVE POSITIONS- WILL HELP US TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT YES
GRAMS PROVIDE. ACCESS TO
PROVING APPROVING HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS BURKE HOW IT
WORKS YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU.
HELLO. NO COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL OKAY- I GUESS MY BEST
MY ONE COMMENT IS IN AND. SO
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND FAMILIES.
WE'RE PREVENTED FROM
HOMELESSNESS OR TAKEN OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS. THOSE WERE
FAMILIES WHO ARE SERVED THROUGH
THROUGH THE PROGRAM THE- EITHER
RECEIVED AT THE TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE WHICH IS- AT THAT
MEANS AMERICANS YOU SHELTER FOR
SIXTEEN DAYS OR THEY RECEIVE
PERMANENT HM WHICH MEANS I
SUPPORT WITH THINGS LIKE I
PAYING FIRST AND LAST MONTH'S
RENT I WENT WHEN MOVING INTO A
PERMANENT HOUSING INTERVENTION.
IN I WOULD LOOK AT IT THIS
SIXTEEN WERE JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE SUCH A SHORT OF IT OF
HOUSING WE HAVE A LOW INCOME
PERSON YOU'RE TRYING TO FIND A
PLACE FOR THEM THAT'S THAT IS
NOT ALWAYS THE EASIEST. THING
TO UNDERTAKE. SO IT REALLY IS
AGAIN ABOUT. A CONNECTING
PEOPLE TO THE ENTIRE HOMELESS
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND GETTING
PEOPLE CONNECTED TO THE LONG
TERM. PERSON BUT THEY'LL NEED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND- THAT
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR IS ONE OF THOSE. ONE
OF THOSE MECHANISM FOR
CONNECTING PEOPLE- YOU. FOR
EXAMPLE RAPID RE HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS WHICH WHICH ARE
ABLE TO PAY RENT THEM PROVIDE
RAPAROUND SPEAK MANAGEMENT-
HELP PEOPLE QUICKLY EXIT
HOMELESSNESS. AND. THEIR OWN
UNIT. IT OPENS IN. ABOUT MARKET
YOU KNOW. WELCOME THANK YOU
HARD I'M A AND I KNOW IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE THAT THAT
SOUNDS LOVELY BUT WE JUST HAVE
TO DRIVE DOWN THE STREET TO SEE
IT'S NOT WORKING OUT VERY WELL
FOR A MAJOR COMPONENT OF OUR
FOLKS ARE TRYING TO TOUCH. OKAY
BERMAN A FINANCE. FURTHER TO
ADD THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYTHING FURTHER SB
CANNON. THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY.
OKAY AND IF WE COULD TAKE BACK
UP. FIVE MINUTE BREAK. OKAY
SMITH A JOURNALIST FOR FIVE
MINUTES THE GERM BUT TAKE A
BREAK. RECESSED THAT'S IT
RECESS THERE'S NO BILL.
KERN
FOR RECESS COMMENCE WITH THE
HEARING AND NEXT WOULD HAVE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT AND I
BELIEVE THE LA- IS GOING TO GO
OVER THOSE FOR US. THE WE'VE
BEEN ASKED. RIGHT AND OR
SOMETHING FROM THE IDEA. MY.
RIGHT HEARD YOU FIND EARLIER.
OKAY AND MY AUDIBLE BUT IT'S
BETTER. OKAY I SEE I'LL I'LL
TRY SPEAKING CLOSER TO MY- WE
WERE ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE TO
PRESENT THESE THESE ARE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS FOR AUGMENTATION BY
EXTERNAL GROUPS ON EACH ISSUE I
WILLPROVIDE THE TITLE AND-
JUST BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF THE
ISSUE THAT DESCRIPTION ONE CREW
THE GROUP THAT IS PROPOSING AND
I JUST TO BE CLEAR. THESE ARE
NOT ALEJO RECOMMENDATIONS AND
ALSO MANY OF THE ISSUES ARE
RELATIVELY NEW TO US SO- WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS-
THE FRST ISSUE IS D. AS TITLED
GLOBAL TELEPHONIC SIGNATURE
SOLUTION- THIS IS FROM THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
REQUEST FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
ONE MILLION ON GOING TO PROVIDE
A SIMPLE. GLOBAL TELEPHONIC
SIGNATURE SOLUTION THAT COULD
BE USED BY ANY COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT
AS DOES NOT OTHERWISE HAVE
ACCESS TO A METHOD OF RECORDING
AND STORING TELEPHONIC
SIGNATURES. THE SECOND IS
TITLED FOOD FOR ALL WE'RE
MODERNIZING THE CALIFORNIA'S
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THIS
ONE SAYS NURSE CALIFORNIA
REQUEST UP TO SIX MILLION
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TWELVE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND FIFTY ONE MILLION IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TO
EXPAND TO SEE FAT TO PROVIDE
STATE FUNDED NUTRITION BENEFITS
TO ANYONE IN ELIGIBLE FOR
CALFRESH SOLELY DUE TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THIS NEXT
ONE IS TITLED SIMPLIFIED
CALFRESH APPLICATION FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND ENSURING FULL
TELEPHONIC ACCESS. NOURISH
CALIFORNIA REQUEST ONE MILLION
A GENERAL FUND AT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO DESIGN AND
INTEGRATE A USER CENTERED
SIMPLIFIED CALFRESH APPLICATION
FOR SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. NURSE CALIFORNIA
ALSO REQUEST THAT THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET INCLUDE
LANGUAGE ENSURING THAT ALL
CALFRESH CLIENTS ARE ABLE TO
COMPLETE ALL FORMS REQUIRING A
CLIENT SIGNATURE. ONLY UPON
COMPLETION OF THE COUNCIL'S
CONSORTIA CONSOLIDATION PROJECT
IN EACH COUNTY RESPECTIVELY. I
AM FOR IS COVERT FOODBANK
SUPPORT OUR STATE EMERGENCY
FOOD BOXES THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
REQUEST ONE HUNDRED TEN MILLION
ONE TIME FOR STATE EMERGENCY
FOOD BANK BOXES. NUMBER GC FOOD
BOXES RATHER. I AM FIVE REESING
CAL WORKS FAN S. DURING COVERT
NINETEEN WHETHER. VETERANS
BASED ONLINE POSITIVE PARENTING
PROGRAMS- POSITIVE PARENTING
PROGRAM OR TRIPLE P. REQUESTS
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION ONE TIME
TO BE EXPENDED OVER THREE YEARS
TO PROVIDE. SUPPORT TO CAL
WORKS FAMILIES. I AM SIX IS
PANDEMIC READY FOR CAL WHICH
FAMILIES. THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATE. REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO EXEMPT
ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
THAT EXCEED THE REGULAR
CALCULATED UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT
LEVEL. AND HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED
BECAUSE OF A THROUGH A STATE OR
FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
FOR PURPOSES OFDETERMINING
DETERMINING L. THIRTY FOR
CALIFORNIA RECIPIENTS AND
APPLICANTS. C. OUR FRIENDS OR
OTHER ELECTRONIC MEANS. EIGHTY
IDENTIFICATION VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENT FOR CAL WORKS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. NUMBER SEVEN IS
THE CAL WORKS GOOD BECAUSE
KLAUS **** STOPPER THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO STOP
THE COUNTING OF MONTHS ON A DUE
TO AN INABILITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN WELFARE TO WORK ACTIVITIES.
NUMBER EIGHT IS TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY FAMILIES
RAISE EQUITY RESEARCH. THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION A WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FUND AN EXHAUSTIVE
STUDY OF CAL WORKS AND- IT HAS
ON POOR WOMEN WOMEN OF COLOR.
NUMBER NINE CAL WORKS CAL OR
POLICY REALIGNMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION A WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. I WOULD
ADOPT SOME OR ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR TOWERS POLICY CHANGES
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOALS OF
THE CAL OR PROGRAM. NUMBER TEN
IS A CAL WORKS GRANT INCREASE.
EFFECTIVE OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WELL. ONLINE POVERTY
IN THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
WELL. ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION- AND
SIX HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING.
TO BRING ALL CAO WORKS GRANT
pLEVELS 255% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. READ NUMBER
ELEVEN IS REDIRECTION OF ON
ALLOCATED TENNIS AND CAL WORKS
FUNDS. THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THAT
ANY UNALLOCATED TENNIS OR CAO
WORKS FUNDS BE PLACED IN THE
CHILD POVERTY AND FAMILY
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT SUB
ACCOUNT. AND THAT THE FUNDING
BE USED TO BRING CAL WORKS
GRANTS UP 21100% OF THE
FEDERAL. POVERTY LEVEL. SHE'S
TWELVE CAL WORK SECTION REFORM
TO ACHIEVE PROGRAM EQUITY. THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD LIMIT SANCTIONS AND
PENALTIES WITH AN PROGRAM ONLY
TO THE EXTENT. REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW. REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW C. C. W. R. O.
REQUEST THAT THE SANCTION OR
PENALTY IF THE MINIMUM
ALLOWABLE BY FEDERAL LAW. I AM
THIRTEEN REFORMING CAL WORKS
EIGHT TO PREGNANT PARENTS. THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ALLOWS
COWARDS AID FROM THE DAY OF
PROOF OF PREGNANCY EXEMPTS
PREGNANT PARENTS FROM WELFARE
TO WORK ACTIVITIES UNLESS THE
PARENT VOLUNTEERS. TO
PARTICIPATE. FOURTEEN IN HIS
PROTECTING VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING
COUNTIES TO ISSUE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WAIVERS TO CAL WORKS
PARENTS WHEN THEY ARE DEEMED
ELIGIBLE FOR THE WAIVER. NUMBER
FIFTEEN IS- FIRST. TO REPEAT
ALL THE ONE HUNDRED HOUR RULE
FOR TWO PARENT FAMILIES AND THE
COVERAGE PROGRAM. SIX THANK YOU
I THINK THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH
YOUR CONNECTION. EIGHT UP UNTIL
AGE TWENTY I'M WE GROUP WE
MISSED THE LAST. A I APOLOGIZE
THE TIME. IT ITEM SIXTEEN FROM
WE DIDN'T GET ALL OF SIXTEEN.
OKAY I AM SIXTEEN IS A LINE THE
COW WORKS IN CALFRESH RULES FOR
BENEFICIARIES WITH AN ARREST
WARRANT. THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION. WEST TRAILER BILL
TO ALIGN CAL WORKS IN CALFRESH.
SEVENTEEN IS A LOUD CAL WORKS
CHILDREN TO COMPLETE HIGH
SCHOOL THROUGH AGE TWENTY. THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION ON GOING
IN TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ALLOW CHILDREN ON CAL WORKS TO
COMPLETE THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
REQUIREMENTS BEFORE THEY REACH
THE AGE TWENTY. EIGHTEEN IS
REFORMING CAL WORKS HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO REPEAL
THE H. EIGHT PIECE LIMIT ON
RECEIVING ASSISTANCE TO ONCE
EVERY TWELVE MONTHS. NINETEEN
IS FLEXIBLE FUNDING FOR TIME
SERVICES DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTERED HOUSING PROGRAMS.
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION REQUEST ONE HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME TO BE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FLEXIBLE
RESOURCES FOR DSS ADMINISTERED
PROGRAMS. IN TWENTY IS
STATUTORY FLEXIBILITIES FOR
CALORIES HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND HOUSING AND
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM.
THAT CALIFORNIA WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION REQUEST
THE FOLLOWING STATUTORY
FLEXIBILITIES AND THE H. S. B.
AND THE H. D. H. P. FOR H. S.
P. C. W. D. A. PROPOSES TO
ALLOW. INTERVENTIONS WITH
CLIENTS TO TAKE PLACE PRIOR TO
THE ISSUANCE OF AN EVICTION
NOTICE FROM A CLIENT'S
LANDLORDS. AND FOR H. D. AP.
THE WTA PROPOSES TO MOVE FROM
GRANTS BASED TO AN ALLOCATION
BASED ON DISTRIBUTION PROCESS
AND TO REMOVE THE INTERIM
ASSISTANCE REIMBURSEMENT. AGAIN
THAT'S JUST A BRIEF DESCRIPTION
OF EACH OF THE PROPOSALS- FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. AND I
REFER YOU TO THE AUDIENCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
MENTION THAT THAT ISSUE NUMBER
THREE WITH A TELEPHONIC- SHE
WITH THAT. CALFRESH IS A
CENTERS GOT WINNERS AND HE DOES
HAVE LEGISLATION- THAT
CORRESPONDS WITH THAT AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD IDEA TO ME-
OKAY AND- DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD YOUR
CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND HE SAID HE CAN'T
REALLY ANSWER A LOT OF
QUESTIONS INTERESTING IDEAS AND
I'M SURE WE'LL HEAR MORE FROM
ADVOCATES DURING PUBLIC
COMMENTS- CENTER MELENDEZ IS
NOW LAUNCHING YOUR PAN IS NOW
GONE. SO IF THERE'S NOTHING
ELSE WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. AND I WILL. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO. MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO WITHDRAW YOUR
QUESTION YOU CAN REPEAT THE ONE
ZERO COMMAND AT ANYTIME IF YOU
ARE USING A SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS ONCE AGAIN
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AT
THIS TIME. AND I WOULD TELL
MEMBERS COMMENT. I WOULD JUST
SAY TO THE M. PARTICIPANTS WERE
GONNA TRY TO MAINTAIN YOUR
COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE IF WE
POSSIBLY CAN- AND I WILL AGAIN
READ THE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
WITH THE AXIS FOUR ONE FOUR
ONE. SEVEN SIX ZERO EIGHT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND OUR FIRST
COMIC COMES FROM LINE SEVENTEEN
LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. I'M REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
pASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN BEHALF
OF OUR RURAL IMMIGRANT
FARMWORKERS. WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THE NECKLACE YOU THREE
AND ALSO ITEM TO IN THE
PROPOSALS. HI THIS PROGRAM SO
WE CAN EXPAND AND ENHANCE A
LEGIBILITY ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR-
IMMIGRATION STATUS THIS IS AN-
IMPORTANT. TO DO IT'S A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. WE JUST
BEING ADDED LINES FOR. OUR
FAMILIES WAITING FOR FOOD WE
ALSO SEEN A PUBLIC CHARGE
ISSUE. HAS BEEN HAS HAD A
CHILLING EFFECT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES. I WILL ALSO ON
BEHALF OF FAIRLY FOUNDATION
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL NUMBER
THREE AND THEN ADD THE
PROPOSALS- NUMBER SEVEN. THE
BECAUSE CLOCKS NUMBER A THE
RATE EQUITY PROPOSAL NUMBER
NINE CAL OR POLICY REALIGNMENT
AND NUMBER TEN GRANTS THE
INCREASE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS TIME. THANK YOU WILL
NOW GO TO LINE THIRTY ONE THE
STATE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
HI THIS IS ANDREW SHANE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS- FIRST ONE- SUPPORT
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AND THANK YOU-
SHARE EGGMAN FOR ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT OF COMMENT I WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
REPORTED ABOUT THE EXISTING
RESOURCE ONLY LASTING THROUGH
APRIL. THE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IS IN DIALOGUE
WITH YES THAT OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO GET US THROUGH
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET YEAR- AND SECONDLY
IN TERMS OF S. INDIAN CAN BE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT IF
YOU TELL THE GENDER. ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THAT THE TIMELY
CLEANUP- AND THE DEPARTMENT'S
REQUIREMENTS WE WOULD SUPPORT-
AND WE ARE WORKING ON LANGUAGE
ISSUE- RIGHT FOR REPLACEMENT
BENEFITS DURING DISASTER- AS
WELL AS STEM THE TURNOUT
PROGRAM. FINDING REGARDING
CALFRESH- WE SUPPORT THE B. C.
P. I WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT-
DISTRIBUTION UNIT AMONG THE
OTHER CONDITIONS THESE REALLY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES
OF A CBO'S IN THOSE THAT- WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT- AND THEN
OUR SUPPORT FOR VERY PROPOSALS.
NUMBER ONE- TELEPHONIC ACCESS
IS AS WELL AS TWO AND THREE YOU
MODERNIZE SIMPLIFY CALFRESH.
ACCESS FOR OLDER ADULTS IN THE
APPLICATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS CHAU EGGMAN- EXPAND
THE CALIFORNIA- WHAT. IS THIS
PROGRAM SEEK OUT. I'M AND THE
COUCH REPORT THAT WE ARE NEEDED
AND REALLY. ALL THE ABOUT
MAKING SURE WERE. NOT LOSING
FOCUS TURN IN THE PROGRAM AND
CALPERS. AND MAINTAINING FROM
THE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU AND YOU. TEXT COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT'S LINE NINE
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. HI YOUR CALL WITH
YOURSELF WHEN YOU WERE
COMMENTING IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE REQUEST FOR A
SIMPLIFIED CALPERS APPLICATION
FOR OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AS WELL AS
EIGHT FIVE TELEPHONIC SIGNATURE
FOR CALFRESH IS. SOMETHING WE
SHOULD'VE DONE A LONG TIME AGO
AND GET THAT DONE THIS YEAR
ALSO SUPPORTING OF COURSE THE
FOOD FOR ALL REQUESTS FROM
MODERNIZE THE CALIFORNIA.
PROGRAM HI WE ARE SUPPORT THE
KOBE TRUE BIG FUNDING AND THE
S. AND P. YEAH. BE REQUIRED.
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
BEFORE THE NEXT CALL JUST AS
THAT WE CAN SEE ROOM MORE
TWELVE AND THERE ARE NO PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING IN THERE AND
NOBODY'S FOR REMOTE ACCESS SO
ALL OF OUR- PUBLIC COMMENTS
WILL BE BY PHONE TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THAT LINE. TWENTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TYLER INDEED WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND- WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND ADMINISTRATION FOR
PLACING ATTENTION UPON THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR INVESTMENT IN
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING THE APPLE
PIE AT THE RATE I'M THROUGH THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION. BOND THAT THE
DENTAL CARE FACILITY-
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES ARE
CRITICAL TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
WITH YOUR MENTAL ILLNESS WHO
ARE UNABLE TO LIVE ON THEIR OWN
PARENTS SUPPORT I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT I AM MENTIONED IN THE
TESTIMONY TODAY THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOSING. A LOT SEVERAL YEARS AND
IF THE MEETING TO SOME-
COMPOUND INTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF BAD SMOG FOR INDIVIDUAL BOND
REMAINING IN PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITY- I'M AN INDIVIDUAL
BETTER UNABLE TO TRANSITION OUT
OF BOND EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
ON THE KNOCKED THEM BOTH OF THE
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT THAT
FUNDING WILL SERVE INDIVIDUALS
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND HOW THE FUNDING
CAN. IN BOTH THE FACT THAT WE-
HELLO OUR FROM THE STATE THANK
YOU THANK. YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT'S LINE THIRD
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND BUT HE AND I
WOULD KEEP PUBLIC ON HOPPNER
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP. IN ORDER TO
CAL WORKS ME MEN TAKE CAL WORK
FROM PROGRAM AT PROVIDE
HUNDREDS ARE YEARS LONG
EVIDENCE PRO TO FOR TIME INCOME
WOMEN AND THEIR NEWBORN BABIES.
LAST YEAR INCLUDED A ONE TIME
EMAIL DOLLARS TO HOME VISITING
SERVICE THROUGH CAL WORK AS ONE
OF THE EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS
INCLUDING PUBLIC SOME VISITING
WE'VE BEEN IN REGULAR
COMMUNICATION WITH DFS TO
ENSURE FAMILIES CAN CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE NFU'S LIFELINE
PURPOSES THROUGH TELEHEALTH
VISITS. BECAUSE HE WORKS WITH
SPECIALLY TRAINED PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES EVEN TELEHEALTH VISITS
BEEN IMPACTED BECAUSE OF OUR
WORKFORCES. REFINEMENT TO CO
THAT RESPONSE. WE GREATLY A-
YES OF WORK TO ENSURE.
INTEGRATION OF COLUMBUS IN THE
WORK BUT WE'RE CONCERNED
PROGRAM IS MODIFIED TO TRACK
MOMENT TREND. RESULTING COUNTY
IS NOT BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
THEIR BUDGET TO BUILD. OUT OF
THE NUMBER OF L. G. FAMILY.
ONLY A PROPER OF THEM FIND A
WAY INTO HOME AND CALIBER
MINISTER. IS PROVEN. TO IMPROVE
AND INFANT HEALTH OUTCOMES
EARLY CHILDHOOD LEARNING AND
FAMILY ECONOMIC SELF
SUFFICIENCY. YES WE'VE BEEN A
TRUE ADVOCATE FOR THE PLAN
BASED THROUGH THEIR PROGRAM IN
ITS DIRECTOR JOHNSON ACTUALLY
MENTIONED THE BEGINNING WITH
THE STEERING. FOR FAMILIES OR
THOSE HIT HARDEST BY THE HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE HAVE THE STATE CAN
HELP REBUILD THE KELBERG FROM
DIVIDEND BUDGET. IS NOW MANY
ELIGIBLE FAMILY POSSIBLE AND
HELP THEM FIND PLACEMENT.
SERVICE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. AND THAT COMES
TO MIND FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MAN CARE RANKS
TENSION ON BEHALF OF TRIPLE P.
POSITIVE PARENTING TRIPLE P. AS
A SPONSOR OF INVESTMENT
PROPOSAL NUMBER FIVE WHICH
PROVIDE ONLINE ACCESS POSITIVE.
PROGRAMS TO HELP WORKS FAMILIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE JUST SIMPLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
EXPIRATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I SOME
POSITIVE PARENTING SKILLS
MYSELF NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND THAT COMES FROM
LINE NINETEEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY THUNDERWING
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
SEVERAL CWD A PROPOSAL IN THE
AGENDA ITEMS ONE SIX NINETEEN
AND TWENTY AS PRESENTED BY THE
L. A. O. I WOULD PARTICULARLY
LIKE TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
FLEXIBLE FUNDING CALL FOR
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO THOSE.
WHO ARE SERVED BY OUR PROGRAMS
WE ARE REQUESTING THIS TO BE
ADOPTED IN THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE AS YOU KNOW COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
ADMINISTER SEVERAL HOUSING
RELATED PROGRAMS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WE
SERVE. OUR RECIPIENTS ARE AMONG
THE MOST VULNERABLE FAMILY
EXPECTED TO EXPERIENCE
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVE
AFFECT WELL BEYOND THE PANDEMIC
WHICH IS WHY WE REQUEST THIS
ONE TIME FUNDING TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. PM GENDER
SUMMARIZES ALL OF OUR PROPOSALS
WHILE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU YOUR STAFF THE
ADMINISTRATION COMMITTEE'S.
REQUEST FOR WORK. WE WILL BE
FOR ONE KINDA AND THAT YEAR
BUDGET. TO ROUGHLY THE CASE
INCREASE DUE TO THE FOR STUDENT
RULES THAT MAY HERNANDEZ FOR
CDS AFTER. WE HAVE LAW FOR LIST
OR ELIMINATING THESE ROLES AND
ARE REALLY EXCITED TO BRING A
POTENTIALLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF NEW CASE. HOWEVER
DUE TO THE INCREASED HOW FRESH
DEMAND WE'VE SEEN THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC WE CANNOT ABSORB A
SIGNIFICANT NEW CASE. WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
DRUG FINER NUMBERS AND WE'LL
CIRCLE BACK WITH YOUR STAFF AT
THAT IF POSSIBLE WITH A
DETAILED REQUEST. WE ALSO ARE
ASKING FOR EARLY ACTION ON THIS
ITEM IT IS A. CHANGE OF ALREADY
BEING IN EFFECT NOW. WITH TO K.
WORK CASELOAD WE WERE HAVE.
THAT YOU HAD EARLIER ABOUT
THIS. AND WE THANK THE L. A. O.
FOR SUGGESTING THAT WE ALL
THINK ABOUT HOW TO INCREASE IT
FURTHER. OR AT LEAST STOP THE
DECLINE FROM PEOPLE EXITING. WE
HAVE SOME IDEAS ON THAT AS WE
KNOW OTHER ADVOCATES DO. AND
WILL BE REACHING OUT TO STAFF
FROM BOTH HOUSES TO SHARE OUR
SUGGESTION. FINALLY WE WANT TO
SUPPORT THE REQUEST IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS. AND NORRIS CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE IN YOUR AGENDA. WITH
THESE AND OTHER PROPOSALS THAT
WE MAY BE ASKED TO WEIGH IN ON.
WE DO WANT TO KNOW AN IMPORTANT
THING TO REMEMBER IS THAT THEY
COUNTIES ARE IN THE PROCESS. OF
MOVING FROM THREE AUTOMATION
SYSTEMS. INTO ONE LARGE SYSTEM
CALLED HEALTH SIDE. AND
AUTOMATION HIGHLIGHTS WILL NEED
TO BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT. WE
TYPICALLY PROVIDE INPUT TO THE
SPONSORS A PROPOSAL LIKE THIS.
AS WELL AS YOUR STAFF. FOR THE
LEVEL OF EFFORT AND POTENTIAL
TRAINING FOR MAKING CERTAIN
ADJUSTMENTS. CAN BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION DURING OUR BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME HAPPY. ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MOVE FORWARD.
THE YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
AND THAT'S LINE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JACQUELINE
CATHOLIC AT THE ANNUAL HUNGER
COALITION AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF PROPOSAL NUMBER
THREE THE IMPLIFIED HEALTH
FRESH APPLICATION AND
TELEPHONIC ACCESS. HERE IN SAN
DIEGO WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHT THOUSAND LOW INCOME
SENIORS THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH WITH ONLY
20% CURRENTLY ACTIVE IN THE
PROGRAM WE WORK WITH AN
EXTENSIVE NETWORK OF CALFRESH
APPLICATION THE SISTER THING
OLDER ADULTS THE CALFRESH
INCONSISTENTLY FEARS OF THE
BARRIERS AND APPLICATION
PROCESS IS CONFUSING AND
CUMBERSOME. THIS WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS IN
SAN DIEGO CURRENTLY MISSING OUT
ON SKULL FRACTURE AND DAMAGE OF
THIS PROGRAMME DURING HOLDEN.
AND BEYOND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THAT COMES FROM LIVE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN MRS REBECCA
GONZALEZ FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ONE OF
SUPPORT I NEED TO READ IF
SUPPORT CALFRESH SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION AND ITS RIPPLE
TELEPHONE ACCESS- I ALSO WANT
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSAL TO IMPROVE SMB N. T.
N. B. BENEFIT AMOUNT AND ALL
THE REPLACE. ASSEMBLY ANTEON BE
BENEFITS FOR FOOD LOCKED DURING
A HOUSEHOLD OR MAJOR DISASTER
AND HOLD THE FAMILY HARMLESS
AND THAT'S KIND OF NEAT ADNATE-
WE ALSO WANT TO PARTY AND BE
AUTHORIZATION DURING CO BAD I
ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD BY THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA BUT FAR
RIGHT ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. CONCERNING HOW WORK-
THAT'S ANOTHER AT A GROUP OF
FOLKS THAT DEFINITELY NEED MORE
HELP AND NOW MORE THAN. EVER
THANK YOU THINK I MIGHT. NEXT
COMMENT. THANK YOU LINE THIRTY
FOUR YOU LINE IS A. BUT I'M
SURE MY CURL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ALONG POVERTY THANK YOU
FOR THIS HEARING TODAY- ARE YOU
ONE OF THE BIG THREE A BRIEF
COMMENTS FIRST IS THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION THAT.
THE COMMITTEE HAD- ON THE
TOWERS CASELOAD- WE AGREE WITH
WATER DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
THAT THERE ARE MANY- STEPS THAT
WE COULD TAKE THAT WOULD PULL
FROM INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO CAN GET INTO THE
PROGRAM AND- NEED TO BE ON OUR
CENTER. USED TO CHURN THAT WE
HAVE SEEN OCCURRING IN RECENT
MONTHS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
IMPLEMENT TOOK SEVERAL OF THOSE
IDEAS DURING THIS BUDGET YEAR
SECOND- WE WANT TO. BRING TO
THE COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION THE
ISSUE OF THE COWART'S GRANTS
WHILE WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
BRING CREEK THE GRANT BY ONE
POINT 5% THIS OCTOBER WE DON'T
THINK THAT THAT FULFILLS THE
OBLIGATION THAT WE MADE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO BRING THE
GRANT UP 250% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL BY FAMILY SIZE.
PLUS ONE WHICH IS EFFECTIVELY
BRING THE GRANT THE 55% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL WE MET
THE FIRST TWO STEPS ON THAT IN
PREVIOUS YEARS LAST YEAR
OBVIOUSLY WE DIDN'T GET THERE
WITH THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BUDGET. BUT NOW WE THINK WE
NEED TO GET BACK ON TRACK AND
TAKE THE THIRD STEP AND FINISH
OFF WITH. THE COMMITMENT THAT
WE MADE THREE YEARS AGO AND
THEN FINALLY I JUST WANT TO
ENDORSE THE PROPOSAL- THAT CAME
OUT ON S. N. B. T. N. B. AND
THE OTHER FOOD PROPOSAL IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE REDUCE
CHURN- FOR THE SMB TMB PROGRAMS
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
REPLACEMENT BENEFITS- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TO
COMMITTEE THERE MANY MANY
HOLES. IN YOUR DOCKET TODAY
THAT DESERVE CONSIDERATION AND
WE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU
OVER THE COMING MONTHS THANK
YOU THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. I HAVE BEEN YOU
AND THAT COMES TO MIND SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR AFTERNOON I'M JEFF
MARSTON SPEAKING I BEHALF OF
THE FOOD BANK FOR ST DIEGO. IN
SAN DIEGO IS VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF PROPOSAL THREE FOR
SIMPLIFY CAL FRESH APPLICATION
FOR OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUE THE
STATE EMERGENCY FOOD BOX
PROGRAM. AND TO DO SO UNDER
PROPORTIONAL FAIR AND EQUITABLE
MANNER. OUR SERVICE AREA
CONSISTING OF ALL SEND YOU
COUNTY HAS EXPERIENCED A
SERVICE DEMAND AND COST
INCREASE THAT'S NEARLY DOUBLED
IN THE PAST YEAR. AS I BELIEVE
YOU WILL KNOW THE FOOD BOXES
THIS PROGRAM AND WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF ALL THE FOOD BANK
WORKERS AND VOLUNTEERS
STATEWIDE HELPS SUPPORT SAFE
CONTACT FREE DISTRICT
DISTRIBUTIONS TO ADDRESS
INCREASINGLY UNMET NEED.
FEEDING SAN DIEGO RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THE HUNDRED
TEN MILLION REQUESTS TO ADDRESS
BENEFIT ADEQUACY FOR THE
EMERGENCY FOOD BACK TO THE BANK
SHOULD MAKE. FOOD BOX PROGRAM
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND THAT COMES TO MIND
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS BENJAMIN SHALL I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. IN SUPPORT OF THE FOOD
FROM THE BUDGET INVESTMENT TO
BRING EQUITY TO OVERSEE THAT
PROGRAM AND ELIGIBILITY
RESTRICTIONS BASED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS. SO MANY
MORE CALIFORNIANS COULD BE
REACHED WITH CRITICAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE THAT WE MODERNIZE
FEEDBACK. TO ACCURATELY REFLECT
THE NEED TO MAKE UP OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
POPULATIONS. ESPECIALLY VISA
HOLDERS DACA RECIPIENTS TPS
HOLDERS AND THE UNDOCUMENTED
RESIDENTS OF OUR STATE. FABRIC
AND THEY MUST BE INCLUDED IN
ORDER TO CREATE A TRULY
EQUITABLE FOOD SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR STATE HAS THE
POWER AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE C.
PAP MORE INCLUSIVE BE A MODEL
FOR THE REST OF THE NATION.
PLEASE RISEN CIPC URGES THE
COMMITTEE. TO SUPPORT A BUDGET
INVESTMENT AND ELIGIBILITY
RESTRICTIONS AND C. PAP BASED
ON IMMIGRATION STATUS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND NOW TO THE
LINE A TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WAS ADJUSTING ERIC
WITH A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION COUNTY THAT WERE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S LEADERSHIP AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
FOR COWARDS CAL FRESH. HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS IN
RESPONSE THE PANDEMIC IT'S
VITAL TO ENSURE RECIPIENTS CAN
ACCESS THESE CRITICAL SERVICES
AND GET INCREASE SUPPORT DURING
THIS TIME AND THE COUNTY HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO RESPOND TO THE
INCREASED DEMAND- ON THE ISSUE
OF PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS
AMONG OLDER ADULTS THE SECOND
QUARTER OF INCREASED INVESTMENT
PARTICULARLY THOSE INVESTMENTS.
THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH
STRATEGIES OUTLINED IN THE
RECENTLY RELEASED A MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING. I WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LEARN FURTHER
DETAILS. ABOUT THAT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
FOR ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES AND RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL NUMBER
NINETEEN THE SPEED OF VEHICLES
OR- OR HOMELESSNESS FUNDING FOR
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENT. THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. AND THAT LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR THE HUDDLED WITH
WIDENING GROUP SPEAKING BEHALF
OF NEXTGEN CALIFORNIA- WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF BOTH THE
NUMBER THREE SIMPLIFIED
CALFRESH APPLICATION FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND ENSURING FULL
TELEPHONIC ACCESS. AS WE NOW
THE PANDEMIC IS EXACERBATING
ALREADY HIGH LEVELS OF HUNGER
AND HARDSHIP PARTICULARLY AMONG
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES DESPITE FEDERAL
AND STATE INTERVENTION OF THE
MOST RECENT DATA SHOW THAT
OVERALL FOOD INSECURITY HAS
SPIKED TO MORE THAN 25% OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS. THAT
SOME TEN MILLION PEOPLE AND TO
HAVE HIGHER THAN BEFORE THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC BEGAN AS
A PROVEN POSITIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTION AND HOW POOR
ECONOMIC STABILIZER CALFRESH
HAVE THE CRITICAL DOOR ROLE TO
PLAY IN CALIFORNIA NEEDED
COOKING NINETEEN RESPOND AND
LONG TERM RECOVERY EFFORTS YET
ONLY 19% OF ELIGIBLE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS. ARE ENROLLED IN
THE PROGRAM IN FACT CALIFORNIA
RANKED LAST IN THE NATION WHEN
IT COMES TO ENROLLING ELIGIBLE
OLDER ADULTS IN CALFRESH. IN
ORDER TO BETTER CONNECT OLDER
ADULTS WITH ONLINE FEDERAL FOOD
ASSISTANCE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
WE EXERCISE EVERY AVAILABLE
OPTION TO SIMPLIFY ACCESS TO
CALFRESH SO WE FULLY SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL AND THAT WE HOPE
TO SEE IT INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH THANKS COMMON
PLEAS. AT AND THAT COMES FROM
MY- TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM THIS IS
TERRIBLE HELLO ANGELES REGIONAL
BANK- FOR AN ADDITIONAL ONE AND
TEN ONE TIME FOR EMERGENCY FOOD
BOXES PROPOSAL FOR AND GIVING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR BOTH
PROPOSALS WIND Q. AND THREE TO
MODERNIZE AND BOND CALFRESH
ACCESS. ARE KEEPING 13100405%
INCREASE IN PEOPLE WHO SERVED
ROUGHLY NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE PER MONTH THAT'S ONE
INTENDED L. A. COUNTY AND WE DO
NOT ANTICIPATE THAT NEED TO
DROP ANYTIME SOON. YOU'RE A
SERVICES WE REACH MANY
IMMIGRANT HOUSEHOLDS YOU MIGHT
FEEL LEFT OUT OF FEDERAL
BENEFITS AND MANY HOUSEHOLDS
WHO ARE SEEKING SERVICES FOR
THE FIRST TIME AFTER EXHAUSTING
OTHER BENEFIT WITH THEIR
EMERGENCY FOOD BOXES WE WERE
ABLE TO DO YOU WILL WAIT ABLE
TO CARRY OUT LARGE SCALE
DISTRIBUTION TO REACH AS MANY
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY IN SAFE
MANNER. WITHOUT THAT THE BANKS
ARE FACING A FEDERAL FOOD CLIP
WHERE SUPPORT PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDED MILLIONS OF POUNDS OF
FOOD TO FOOD BANKS HAVE SUNSET
IT AND THE IMPACT HE AND OTHERS
CAN BE SEEN IN OTHER STATES
WHERE. STATE FUNDED KNOCKED ON
THE GAPS WHERE FOOD BANKS RAN
OUT OF FOOD IN DECEMBER ONE OF
THE BUSIEST TIMES PERFECT
THANKS CAL PRESSURE THE GREAT
STOPGAP IN THIS PROCESS SO WE
HOPE TO SEE FURTHER INVESTMENT
IN FOOD BOXES AS WELL AS
CALFRESH. WE HOPE TO SEE A
STATE INVEST IN GOOD ACTORS NOW
TO PREVENT FURTHER HUNGER THANK
YOU THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
TIME PLEASE. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE. FIVE WE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY BROOKS
ON BEHALF OF URBAN OF COME. WE
THINK ARE SO FOR THAT COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
PROPOSAL NINETEEN IN
COMFORTABLE FUNDING FOR COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT AND
MINISTER HOUSING PROGRAMS I'M
PROPOSAL NUMBER TWENTY
STARTING- FLEXIBILITY FOR THAT
HOW WORK HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND THE HOUSING AND
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM-
THE URBAN COUNTIES ARE
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN-
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS POLICY
WE LOOK VERY PLEASED VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOUR COMPANY AND THE OTHER
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE IS. ON ALL
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT IMPACT
HOMELESSNESS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN MOVING FORWARD FOR THE
STATE IN THE COUNTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COMING
PLEASE. THANK YOU AN ACTOR FROM
LIVE. FORTY I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- MY NAME IS MARK
SONNTAG MEN ON BEHALF OF THE
PARENTAL POLICY COUNCIL IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO MARIA FOODBANK.
ARE DUE TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSAL TO IMPROVE S. AND
BEING INTOA AND B. BENEFITS-
BY REPLACING S. N. B. C. N. B.
BENEFITS HOPEFUL LOST ON MAJOR
DISASTER SIMILAR TO WATCH FIRST
US. PAUCITY IN RECERTIFICATION
STIR THE PANDEMIC TO STOP STERN
THAT CAUSES A LIFETIME LOSS OF
BENEFITS ALSO THE SIMPLIFIED
ACCOUNT FRANCE APPLICATIONS
VOTER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. ALLOW AKTAU FRESH
PARTICIPANTS TO COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION OF THE FORMS THAT
REQUIRES SIGNATURE BY STRONG
AND BREAK UP THE SSR GRANTS SSG
GRANTS AS WE ARE FROM EVERYONE
ON THIS CALL EVEN DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT A HUNGER NEED TO
START A RULES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC SO WHY SHOULD WE MAKE
THINGS HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO GET
ACCESS TO HEALTH GET YOUR
SIMPLE. LET'S MAKE IT EASY AS
POSSIBLE TO HELP FEED OUR
CALIFORNIANS IN THE SPECIALLY
KEY IS UNDOCUMENTED NEIGHBORS
AND OUR OLDER ADULTS. AND
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS- OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS PETER
EVAN TO PAUL AT THE WITHOUT
UNIT COMMUNITY FOOD BANK WE
WOULD LIKE TO RECORD OUR
SUPPORT FOR PROPOSAL. FIRST WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT FUNDING IN THE
STATE BUDGET CALFRESH
SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION AND
ENSURING FULL TELEPHONE ACCESS
STATE LINE. SECOND THE FOOD
BANK SUPPORT PROPOSAL NUMBER
FOUR PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUE THE
STATE EMERGENCY FOOD BOX
PROGRAM. THIRD WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO IMPROVE
ASKING B. AND T. MP BENEFIT
AMOUNT AND WE CALL ON THE
LEGISLATURE REPLACE BENEFITS
FOR GOOD LUCK DURING THE
DISASTER AND DEPART PMP
RECERTIFICATION THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC. FINALLY WE SUPPORT A
BUDGET INVESTMENT TO BRING
EQUITY TO OUR PROGRAM AND
ELIGIBILITY RESTRICTIONS BASED
ON IMMIGRATION. STATUS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
COMMON PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THAT COMES TO MIND. FIFTY ONE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE SELLING OF OUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR ITEM
THREE THE BUDGET INVESTMENT TO
BRING EQUITY TO THE CALIFONIA.
M. AND ELIGIBILITY RESTRICTIONS
BASED ON IMMIGRATION STATUS.
HALF OF CHILDREN CALIFORNIA
FROM IMMIGRANT FAMILIES MORE
THAN ONE AND A HALF MILLION
HAVE AND UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS.
AND BROTHER MANY CHILDREN LIVE
IN MULTI GENERATIONAL
HOUSEHOLDS. IN ADDITIONAL
MULTIPLE SURVEYS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THAT WE DISTRIBUTED
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE WITH
PARTNERS THAT INCLUDES. BK AND
EDUCATION TRUCK LAST HIGHLIGHTS
THE NUMEROUS STRUGGLE THAT
FAMILIES CONTINUE TO FACE
INCLUDING THE- INSECURITY. AS A
RESULT IN MODERN NINETEEN TO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT YEAH. EIGHT
PEOPLE IMPROVE ACCESS TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND BRING
EQUITY TO THE PROGRAM WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
NOW TO LINE FIFTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS NOW SURE OAK. FIVE OF OFTEN
PAIRED WITH A OUT HE- ON BEHALF
OF THREE POINT THREE MILLION.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA. BOB
BARRIERS TO RUN STREAMLINING
THE PROCESS PROCEDURES TO APPLY
FOR CALFRESH. WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA ONLY SERVE. YEAH
VOTER I'VE TALKED. OUT TO A FOR
IT NOT TRULY. THE TAKE THE
INITIATIVE SUSPEND THE PROCESS.
AND TO ALLOW COMPLETE.
APPLICATION WHICH REQUIRE THAT
YOU'RE- WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO
HELPING SHE HAS AND NOT A
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL. I HAVE TO
WHICH THEY ARE ENTITLED. THAT
IS WHY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND NOW LIVES
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WOULD BE. I THEY DISCONNECTED
HOW WE WILL MOVE TO LINE FORTY
NINE AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE BACK UP Y. FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO. PLEASED TO SELL.
FIVE FORTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR EGGMAN THIS IS ROBERT
NAYLOR I REPRESENTS SIX BEDS HE
IS AN ASSOCIATION OF MORE THAN
TWO THOUSAND ASSISTED LIVING
AND ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES- ALL SIX BEDS OR
LESS WE ARE ON ISSUE SIX
SUPPORTING THE DEPARTMENTS-
WRITTEN THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST
FOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- FOR REHABILITATION
PURCHASE. AS A WAY OF STEMMING
THE CLOSURES OF A. R. S. AND
RCMP'S- THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCED ESPECIALLY IN SOME
MAJOR URBAN AREAS. OF THE SSI
REIMBURSEMENT RATE JUST DOES
NOT COVER THE COST OF AN
INDIVIDUAL SO THIS EXTRA
INCENTIVE MIGHT HELP- IT WAS
NEVER ADJUSTED FOR EXAMPLE FOR
THE INCREASED MINIMUM WAGE AS
WELL AS INCREASED OTHER COSTS-
SIX BED. FACILITIES OCCUPYING
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES ARE A
RELATIVELY EFFICIENT USE OF THE
AVAILABLE HOUSING STOCK.
LEASING THE USE OF THESE
FACILITIES THROUGH THIS KIND OF
PROGRAM COULD HELP. ADDRESS IN
A MODEST WAY AT LEAST ARE
HOMELESS. AND NEAR HOMELESS
PROBLEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
HEADLINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MIKE
DAVIS AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND ADVOCACY OF EXAMPLES
OF THE MARIN FOOD BANK ON
BEHALF OF THE FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS HAVE BEEN
RELYING ON CHARITABLE FOODS
MARKET BANK EVERY WEEK OF THE
FOREIGN DURING THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
FUNDING IN THE STATE BUDGET FOR
A CALFRESH SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION. TO ENSURE FULL
TELEPHONIC ACCESS AS WELL IT
WITHIN OUR POWER TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED HELP
FEEDING THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES IT'S PAST TIME FOR US
TO MAKE IT THE MINISTRY OF
CHANGES AFTER SMALL IN THE BACK
ON HUNGER IS SIGNIFICANT. AND
AS THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE
FOR HUNGER FOR UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE
UNABLE TO ACCESS FEDERALLY
FUNDED FOOD ASSISTANCE. WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FOOD FOR
ALL CAMPAIGNS EFFORTS TO
MODERNIZE THE CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
STATE FUNDED NUTRITION BENEFIT
THE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR CALPERS TO THE
IMMIGRATION STATUS. AND FINALLY
WE ALSO SUPPORT PORTAL NUMBER
FOUR TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUE
THE STATE EMERGENCY FOOD BOX
PROGRAM PRESERVING DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS BOARD
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND STATE
SUPPORT IS VITAL TO OUR ABILITY
TO CONTINUE TO MEET
UNPRECEDENTED NEEDS THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
FORTY. YEAR LINE IS- OPEN.
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS BILL
VANDER CLAY I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF POLICY AND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE NATIONAL DIAPER
BANK NETWORK I THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CHEERING AND
YOUR TIME- BIKE THE FLAG THAT
BEING THE FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TYPE OF PROGRAM- TEN MILLION
AND FUNDING ALLOCATED FOR
DIAPER BAGS- BUT YOU YEARS AGO
AND THEN- A LITTLE. OVER ONE
MILLION OR AT THE ORANGE
COUNTERACTING IT WOULD PROBABLY
SUPPORT- AT THE COMMITTEE TO-
ALLOCATE FUNDING TO CONTINUE
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC ONE IN THREE.
FAMILIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
STRUGGLED TO GET ENOUGH BY
CRITICALLY KEEP THEIR CHILD
CLEAN DRY AND HEALTHY AND WE'RE
STAYING NUMBERS ARE
SKYROCKETING- IN TERMS OF
FAMILIES SEEKING DIAPERS DURING
THE PANDEMIC SO WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- TO MAINTAIN THIS
PROGRAM IN THE YEARS AHEAD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE FIFTY FIVE LINE- MAYBE
SANTA ON BEHALF OF ASEAN CAL
ONE EXPECTED. TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY I
WANT TO ALSO- EXPRESSED
APPRECIATION FOR HAVING A VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
REGARDING THE COMPLICATED
ISSUES SURROUNDING CAL WORKS
CASELOAD PARTICULARLY THE
QUESTION DOCTOR PM REYES
REGARDING THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
WE HAVE LOTS OF IDEAS FOR HOW
TO BETTER ADDRESS THOSE TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE MAXIMIZING CASELOADS
AND HALTING UNNECESSARY
EXPENSE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
REGISTER AND SEE I USED TO
SUPPORT FOR ITEM. ONE THREE SIX
NINETEEN AND TWENTY FOUR
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN KEY
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO CALL IN TODAY
PLEASE LOOK ON OUR WEBSITE YOU
CAN EMAIL THE THAT COMMITTEE
AND REACH OUT YOUR INPUT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO US. WE
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY WHO CALLED
IN TODAY- I THINK THAT WILL WE
WILL CONTINUE ON THIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH A OF. HAVING
TO DO WITH HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES GOING FORWARD. OUR
FIRST HEARING ON HUMAN SERVICES.
AND WE'RE SCHEDULED TO HAVE
MORE- AND WILL CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS FROM. ANYTHING
ELSE FROM THE PERSONAL FINANCE
OR THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES OR THE L. A. L. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS AFTERNOON CHAIR. VITIATED
CHECK THANK YOU. NOTHING
FURTHER FROM THE L. L. THANK
YOU CHRI I THINK THAT'S WRAPPED
THIS ALL UP THEN- I THINK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR TIME AND WE
WILL ADJOURN THIS MEETING.